MonkaW
Ich hatte schon öfters vor heute machen wir krassen progress und das war...
...naja...
Vielleicht nicht ganz so...
...progressiert
Fadel danke für den Sub
Wow
Was ist mit meiner vm los?
Schmallen
Guck mal ich hab gesehen der vierer champ hat noch ein neues issue gekriegt
So langsam wird es glaube ich echt mal Zeit
Ich werde jetzt nicht mehr auf der vm schauen
Das wäre mir einfach zu viel
Also ich werde dann nicht mehr auf der vm schauen
Ich werde jetzt nicht mehr auf der vm schauen
Ich habe nichts mehr zu trinken
Das geht nicht
Da halte ich jetzt kein hiq stream durch ohne was zu trinken
Ich bin in zwei Minuten wieder da
So jetzt aber
Jetzt aber
So ich bin wieder am start
Ähm Leute ich hab übelst Muskelkater
Ich hab
Ich hab mir ja diese Fitness Uhr gekauft
Vor paar Tagen
Und ich hab jetzt meine Wanderrunden
Immer mit Fitness Uhr gemacht
Also mit Fitness Tracker Uhr gemacht
Und
Das regt
Ganz stark dazu an
Schneller und
Anstrengender zu laufen
Als man es eigentlich
Gewohnt ist und mal zu gucken
Wie weit das so geht
Ich bin dann beispielsweise
Ein Stück hochgerannt
Normalerweise renne ich nie
Ein paar Minuten hochgerannt weil ich mal gucken
Wollte
Wie viel ich noch packe
Ich bin wahnsinnig trainiert
Zur Zeit
Das Ding hat ja auch
Pulsmesser und alles mit dabei
Wollte ich mal gucken
Wie hoch ich noch mit meiner Herzfrequenz
Oder so komme
Und das war schon echt anstrengend
Und jetzt habe ich übelst
Muskelkater nicht nur in den Beinen
Sondern fragt mich nicht warum in den Armen
Die habe ich überhaupt nicht gebraucht
Wahrscheinlich
Vom Rennen so von den Armen
Ja
Also 182
Habe ich gerade so noch gepackt da bin ich fast umgekippt
182 Puls
Das war kurz vor verrecken
Das war F
Das war wirklich kurz vor abkratzen
Da habe ich echt geschnauft
Ja
Ne ist echt so
Also früher hatte ich da weniger
Schmerzen aber es geht also ich muss sagen
Ich bin
Ja
Aber nicht lange ne
Ganz kurz in der Spitze
Beim Berghochrennen
Direkt beim stoppen dann
Also so viel nicht
Sonst würde ich es nicht schaffen
Was ich je in meinem Leben gemessen habe
War aber da war ich
Wahrscheinlich
So um die 18
17 irgendwie
In dem Dreh
Das höchste was ich je gemessen habe
Mal auch mit so einem Pulsgurt
War 210
Aber
Das kriege ich heute nicht mehr hin
Ja mit 16 oder mit 16
17 18 ist das auch noch gar kein Problem
Nein
Ernsthaft kein Shit
Aber das ist ganz normal
Dass man das in dem Alter noch hinbekommt
Jetzt auf gar keinen Fall mehr
Laut
Nach der Faustformel wäre meine
Mein maximaler
Ich bin 39
Das kommt doch sehr gut hin oder
Das kommt doch sehr gut hin
Und wenn man nach der Formel geht
Ich meine
Ich will jetzt nicht ausschätzen
Vielleicht noch 1-2 Schläge
Minute
Die Faustformel
Das ist glaube ich 200 minus Lebensalter
Oder so
220 minus Lebensalter
Ja
220 minus Alter
So
Also
Progress Time Leute
Nicht Zeit tracken lassen
Progress
High Performer Mindset
Aktivieren
Also
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Stream
Wir haben ja nicht wirklich viel gemacht
Web
Run
Zack
So
Nein Nein Nein Leute
Wir machen kein Rewrite in Rust
So
Das da
Da müssen wir Rider aufmachen
Fürs Backend
Und dann erzähle ich euch was wir machen
Für alle die nicht dabei waren
Warum habe ich keine
Verknüpfung mehr dahin
Okay
Repos
Backend
Open
Trust
Okay gut
Konsole
Backend
.Net
Run
Ich bin mir da nämlich gar nicht mehr so sicher
Ich glaube wir haben nicht wirklich viel auf die Reihe gekriegt
Unser Backend ist doch äußerst minimalistisch
Noch würde ich sagen
Außer Results Cack W
Das ist natürlich das worauf die Welt gewartet hat im Endeffekt
So
Wir stellen jetzt erstmal was anderes um
Leute ich hab mich jetzt
Gehört
Rewrite was ist das denn
Rust Web Framework oder was
Build Fast Moment nicht Blazingly Fast
Dann use ich das nicht
Also unter Blazingly Fast mach ich nicht
Und zwar Chat ich hab auf euch gehört
Irgendjemand oder was heißt irgendjemand
Viele Leute
Nicht irgendjemand sondern relativ viele Leute haben mir gesagt
Max du bist immer am hin und her
Switchen zwischen
Verschiedenen
Verschiedenen Spaces im Editor und sowas
Warum benutzt du nicht einfach Tabs
Dann ist das Zeichen immer das gleiche
In der Datei aber die Anzeige bei dir
Variiert und das mach ich jetzt
Ich stell jetzt einfach Tab um auf
Anzeige für 2 Spaces aber es bleibt immer noch Tab
Das heißt
Bei euch könnten es 8 Spaces sein
Bei mir sind es 2 Spaces
Es ist einfach nur ein Tab
Und es sieht vor allem für mich einheitlich aus
Ohne dass ich jedes Mal in diese Datei umstellen muss
So
Da sind wir hier sind wir stehen geblieben
Also Chat geht
Ich erzähl euch jetzt mal was wir kurz machen
Ich hab einen Addon für Home Assistant
Programmiert wo man Daten über
Sein Elektroauto abfragen kann
Das ist aber jetzt nicht so wild
Es gab ein paar Feature Anfragen
Ob man das nicht besser Stand Alone
Benutzbar machen kann
Und
Noch ein paar andere Sachen
Ob man das einbauen kann
Ich hab mir das angeguckt paar Sachen werden wir einbauen
Wir werden zum Beispiel einbauen
Das ist Skeleton UI
Dass mehrere Hersteller möglich sind
Gleichzeitig
Also falls jetzt irgendjemand ein Jeep und ein Fiat hat
Dann geht das, das ging bisher nicht
Das war bescheuert
Damit hab ich nicht gerettet ehrlich gesagt
Also ich hab nicht damit gerechnet
Dass Leute damit ein Jeep und ein Fiat hinzufügen wollen
Ich hätte gedacht die haben ein Jeep oder ein Fiat
Ich hab da einfach nicht dran gedacht
Und dann vielleicht mehrere Fiats oder so
Da hab ich nicht mit gerechnet
Das funktioniert nicht
Deswegen für besseren Stand Alone Betrieb
Und für besseres Konfigurieren
Kriegt das Ding ein Web Interface
Aktuell sieht der Konfig Dialog so aus
Das ist der Home Assistant Native
Konfig Dialog
Da kann man nur eine Account eingeben
Und eine PIN und sowas
Und halt nicht pro
Pro Hersteller Account
Man kann quasi nur eine Account und einen Hersteller auswählen
Fertig mehr geht nicht
Und ein paar Leute haben auch gefragt
Ob man das nicht Stand Alone benutzen kann
Ja warum nicht
Also Stand Alone heißt im Endeffekt
Dass man ein Konfig Interface
Konfig Möglichkeit braucht
Und dann in MQTT Server angeben kann
Wo das seine Daten hinschickt
So
Junge immer wenn ich mit CTRL
Meine Files poliere
Ja also bei Javascript bin ich da auch noch
Irgendwie ein bisschen planlos
Manchmal formatiert der mir auch meine Javascripts
Und es sieht kacke aus danach
So und heute kümmern wir uns um das Web Interface
Das Web Interface wird super
Basic
Das Web Interface bekommt quasi zwei Seiten nur
Es bekommt eine Übersichtsseite über alle Accounts
Die geedet werden mit einer Anzeige
Ob das alles funktioniert
Und es gibt einen
Ja Account hinzufügen Formular
Und das wars
Mehr wird es nicht geben im Web Interface
Das heißt ich hoffe
Dass wir heute recht gut Progress im Web Interface machen
Als ich das soweit fertig kriege
Allerdings fertig werde ich es heute nicht kriegen
Aber dass ich das in nächster Zeit
Halbwegs fertig kriege
Das ist tatsächlich
Das ist SvelteKit
Das ist Skeleton UI
Als
Komponent Library
Oder wie man das nennt
Schaut so aus
Oh es gibt jetzt sogar einen Skeleton Store
Das ist neu
Nehmen wir bloß weg
Skeleton Store was gibt es denn da heute
Spaceman
99 Dollar
Ok Leute jetzt weiß ich auch
Warum die Default Themes so kacke sind
Das ist damit man sich
Die
Professional Themes kauft
Wobei so kacke sind die Default Themes
Gar nicht
Ich finde das Modern Theme eigentlich ganz gut
Wenn man auf Material Design steht
Mir persönlich gefällt Rocket
Am besten
Das Normale ist auch ganz ok
Wobei was ich halt gar nicht mag
Ist das da
Und
Das ist
Ey wer hat sich das ausgedacht
Wir lassen es einfach mal Default
Ja wir können auch ein eigenes
Theme bauen das ist tatsächlich relativ
Einfach
Die haben nämlich hier einen
Theme Generator
Das war mir jetzt nett
Aber ich wollte es euch nochmal kurz zeigen
Spooky Musik
Hier die haben einen Theme Generator
Da kann man zum Beispiel einstellen
Es gefällt einem das Grün
Hier nicht
Ganz ehrlich ich persönlich
Mag kein Grün
Als Primary Hintergrund
Das wollte ich mir tatsächlich auch mal
Angucken ich meine wir sind hier nicht in
React das heißt wir können das Originale nicht
Verwenden aber es gibt ja auch
Ein Projekt ins Welt was sich
Daran ein bisschen orientiert
Der Unterschied zwischen dem was ich benutze
Und dem ist
Im Endeffekt hier sind es fertige Components
Die dann auch geupdated werden
Wenn das kaputt ist bei
Wie spricht man das überhaupt aus
Shadden UI
Da sind das ja nur Sachen zum rein
Kopieren
Oder zum rein installieren
Wo man dann selbst dran rumwursten muss
Hast du irgendwas am Frontend Rendering
Verändert das Stream sieht blurry aus
Nee
Hast du die falsche Auflösung
Bei mir sieht es vollkommen okay aus
Ich gucke gerade in Vorschau
Ich hab gerade die Vorschau auf
Das sieht komplett scharf aus
Ohne jeglichen Blur
Flowbyte hab ich mir mal angeguckt
Da gab es irgendwas dran was mir nicht gefallen hat
Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr genau was
Irgendwas hat mir daran nicht gefallen
Flowbyte sieht default mäßig optisch
Deutlich besser aus
Vielleicht macht AWS
Badge
So
Gut
Also
So viel
Was ich hier zeigen wollte
Taskbar sieht scharf aus
Alles andere nicht
Könnt ihr das in irgendeiner Art und Weise bestätigen
Ich hab
Ich hab bei mir die Vorschau auf
Auf der linken Seite
Das ist
Absolut
Komplett
Ich könnte noch nicht mal den Unterschied zwischen den
Bildschirmen erkennen
Im Fullscreen
Außer dass der linke ein bisschen dunkler ist
Weil der gescheit kalibriert ist
Refresh mal ein paar mal die Seite
Ich weiß nicht was da kaputt ist
Also
Die haben hier einen Theme Generator
Kann man sagen
Also wenn man zum Beispiel
Ey guck mal
Light
Theme hier grün gefällt mir nicht
Kann ich hier draufklicken und sagen
Ich will das in blau haben
Oh jetzt hab ich's reset
Sehr schlau
So und jetzt hat man das Primary in blau
Ehrlich gesagt
Find ich das deutlich angenehmer
Als das mit dem grün
Ich mag das
Ich mag das grün als Primary Color einfach nicht
Für Success Anzeigen vollkommen okay
Das hier für Warnung
Ganz ehrlich
Ich würde die Secondary Farbe
Ehrlich gesagt als Primary Farbe bevorzugen
Das hier
Wir lassen uns jetzt aber
Ansonsten machen wir viel zu viel an der Optik rum
Anstatt es jetzt mal ein bisschen zu progressen
Gut
Also wo fangen wir an
Ich glaube ich hab jetzt halbwegs
Ja hat man verstanden was ich machen will oder
Zum konfigurieren von meinem
Hier
Elektroauto Ausleseprogramm
Aktuell ist da nichts
Implementiert im Backend
Das macht gar nichts
Das hat ein APN Punkt
Und die Results sind keck weh
Wenn man es aufruft
Zumindest so ein bisschen
Damit fangen wir vielleicht sogar mal an
Ich brauche ein bisschen Fake Daten
Dass ich überhaupt ordentlich was anzeigen lassen kann
Im Frontend
Es gibt keine zweite Seite
Die Buttons machen nichts
Ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt erstmal mit etwas Einfachem an
Und zwar
Wir
Packen das hier mal
Würde ich sagen
Wir packen mal
Diese Karte
Das da
Das packen wir in eine eigene Komponente
Dass es irgendwie halbwegs
Übersichtlich bleibt
Account
So richtig
Schreiben könnte
Gibt es jetzt vielleicht irgendwelche Refactor Dinger
Hier über Visual Studios und nach dem Motto
Leg mir eine Datei an
Nee gell
Das muss man von Anfang an
Das wäre natürlich cool
Wenn ich das hier schreiben könnte und würde jetzt sagen
Erstell mir eine Komponent die es noch nicht gibt
Das geht nicht
Extract Komponent gibt es
Das heißt im Endeffekt
Ich gehe hier hin und sage
Geht wie das Welt
Ich habe das Addon aber dran
Hier Refactor
Nö
Ach guck mal hier
Achja das ist ja cool
Extract Komponent
So das heißt jetzt Account
Ähm Moment Leute
Komponents immer groß oder klein schreiben
Ich kann mir das
Welttechnisch nicht merken
Ich glaube groß
Groß
Ja
Und in Lib
In Lib
Ups
Ach hier Extract
Komponent
Account Card
Hat das jetzt unter Lib angelegt
Ach hier hat das hin
Weil ich glaube die soll man ja immer unter Lib
Speichern
Jetzt wird er das natürlich nicht
Finden
Guck mal
Hat er das oben gerade
Boah guck mal
Das Addon ist ja richtig schlau
Ich track und drop das in Lib
Und Bäm
Benennt das da oben um
Das ist ja Massive
High IQ Shit
Pogu
Okay schick
So unsere komische
Fake API Funktion schmeißen wir klein mal raus
Die brauchen wir nicht
Die brauchen wir an der Stelle auch nicht
Und Icons brauchen wir hier
Im Prinzip auch nicht
Okay wunderbar
Account Card
Funktioniert wieder
Bäm Bäm Bäm
Ja das ganze API
Zeug das lassen wir einfach mal weg
Ich mein das müssen wir dann machen
So okay
Dann haben wir das erstmal als
Extra Komponent extra hier
Macht doch
Ja das verstehe ich nicht
Warum das so oft
Gemacht wird weil
Guck mal wenn ich sag
Punkt Punkt Slash
Ups doch nicht
Dann hab ich Autocomplete
Aber witzigerweise
Wenn ich sag Dollar Lib
Dann hab ich kein Autocomplete
Also
Dann lassen wir es doch lieber so
Wo ich Autocomplete hab
Dann fangen wir jetzt mal mit was Grundlegendem an
Du hast das echt wie hast du das gemacht
Dass du hier Autocomplete hast
Vielleicht muss man irgendwie Lib
Explizit muss man das irgendwie
Einschalten im
Irgendwo im
In den Settings
Von dem Addon
Es ist kein Typescript Projekt
Vielleicht deswegen
Vielleicht weil es kein Typescript
Project ist
Funktioniert Twitch nicht mehr richtig
Ja anscheinend hab ich auch gerade gehört
Dass
AWS gerade Bett getimed hat
Gut
Okay ich würde sagen
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal ein paar ganz grundlegende Sachen machen
Damit wir das hier schön interaktiv bekommen
Also
Aktuell ist ja dieser Spinner und so
Das ist ja alles nur Placeholder
Ich würde sagen
Wir generieren jetzt erstmal
Ein bisschen Fake Daten
Damit ich was zum Anzeigen hab
Ja
Also machen wir mal Backend
Machen wir das Backend aus
Ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt tatsächlich erstmal
Bevor wir uns jetzt wieder an irgendwelchen optischen Sachen hier aufhängen
Ob was jetzt schön ist oder nicht schön ist
Und wie die Karte Design sein soll
Wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen Background Zeug
Was wir eh brauchen
Weil ich mein ein AP Endpunkt mit Slash ID
Und Result Keg W ist vielleicht nicht so das was man braucht
Okay also
Lass mal überlegen
Hm
Use File Server
Das haben wir, dass ich aus www.root Sachen
Surfen kann
Ne ne Twitch
Ist gerade kaputt Schatz
Okay also wir generieren jetzt mal ein bisschen
Fake Daten
Dazu gibt es eine super Library für .NET
Die nennt sich Bogus
Bogus
Das hier
Und da kann man Fake Daten generieren
Wir brauchen eine Klasse
Public Class
Ich mach das jetzt mal relativ unschön
Hier alles in der Datei rin
Also wir brauchen einen Account der angelegt werden kann
In dem Account stehen dann so Sachen drin
Wie Username, Passwort
Irgendeine ID, Region für das Auto
Und solche Geschichten
Also es gibt dann sowas wie ein Account
Wobei nennen wir es mal nicht Account, nennen wir es mal Uconnect
Account
Dieser Online Service von Fiat und Jeep
Und so es heißt ja Uconnect
Uconnect Account
Das Ding kriegt
Required
Können wir mal neue C-Sharp Features verwenden
Required String
User
Dann
Braucht das
Ein
Eine ID
Machen wir das mal lieber so
Braucht eine ID
Dass jeder Account eine eigene ID hat
Muss man die Dinger irgendwie
Identifizieren und unterscheiden können
Dann brauchen wir
Einen
E-Namen für den Hersteller
Und die Region vom Auto
Also wenn man sowas hier
Jetzt muss ich mal testen
Wie gut Rider das hinbekommt
Kann ich sowas machen wie
Uconnect
Region
Jetzt machen wir Region
Und jetzt gibt es das nicht
Und jetzt kann ich sagen Create Type
Ja gut aber da weißt du doch gar nicht was ich haben will oder
Ja dann mach
Ach hier kann ich jetzt
Cool Systemada guck mal da
Also man muss echt sagen
Das JetBrains Zeug ist schon
Nett verkehrt ne
So Regionen gibt es
Europe, Asia
Und Amerika
Das nenne ich tatsächlich so
Weil dann fühlt sich sowohl
NA als auch
SA und
MA angesprochen
Falls man das so
Abkürzt
Das hab ich bei mir im Webinterface hier
In dem alten Konfig Dialog
Hieß das auch so
Oh ich hab noch gar kein
Ich hab noch gar kein Screenshot davon gemacht
Man kann da mittlerweile auch einfügen
Die Region
Da gab es nämlich das Problem das Leute
Aus den USA versucht haben
Zu Fiat EU zu connecten
So als nächstes
Ok da brauchen wir noch einen E-Namen
Und zwar
Wenn ich das mal schreiben könnte
Wir brauchen noch einen E-Namen für
EU Connect
Leute was ist die korrekte Bezeichnung
Für einen Hersteller
Sowas wie Brand
Ist Fiat
Ne Brand oder ne
Oder ne Vendor oder
Wie nennt man das
Ich nenne es einfach mal Brand
Vendor
Zumindest gibt es Fiat
Jeep
Manufacturer
Ok das ist mir zu lang
Ich lass es einfach
So Fiat
Jeep Ram
Dodge
Und Alfa
Alfa Romeo
Gibt es
Gut
Da gibt es nicht ne Region
Brand
Ja ist gut
So
Was brauchen wir denn sonst noch in so einem Account
Wir brauchen Autos
Im Endeffekt
Make
Make heißt doch sowas wie
Erstellen und nicht Hersteller
Oder vielleicht nennen die das auch so
Ohne dass mir das jetzt
So weit bewusst ist
Wir lassen es jetzt erstmal so
Weil ansonsten hängen wir uns an so kleinen Scheiß auf
Wir brauchen noch ein Auto
Public Class Uconnect
Car
So und so ein Auto hat das aller wichtigste
Hab ich mittlerweile gelernt
Seit ich mit der Fiat API
Und den Uconnect Sachen zu tun hat
Jedes Auto hat eine FIM
Oder
Ich glaube in Deutsch heißt es FIM
Fahrzeug Identifikations
Nummer
Also ich glaube
String
Model
Dann
Oh ich hab noch ne Idee
Wir machen noch
Das Hersteller
Wir brauchen ein bisschen Daten
Dass ich ordentlich das Frontend ausprobieren kann
So
Dann machen wir nochmal ne Location
Double
Long
Ich glaub das reicht fürs Auto
So und das hier
Bekommt eine Liste aus
Autos noch dabei
Also mal Cars
Ich glaube das reicht im Großen und Ganzen auch
Mal kurz im Chat was gucken
Äh
Hab ich schon, wie gesagt Twitch funktioniert bei mir
Aber ich hab jetzt schon ein paar mal im Chat gesehen
Dass AWS ein bisschen
Bedgetime Modus hat
So Uconnect Account
Dann
Ein Feld machen wir noch
Date Time
Up
Dated
Das ist immer praktisch
Wieder Webinterface für mein
Addon
Für mein
Elektroauto Auslesetool
Wie gesagt es gibt ein ziemlich minimalistisches
Webinterface
So das reicht mehr brauchen wir nicht
Und jetzt erstellen wir Fake Daten
Für den Krempel
Wie macht man das jetzt am besten
Also haben wir sowas hier
Car gleich
Faker Uconnect
Account
Ha
Boah da weiß ich nicht
Fokus getappt, wie funktioniert der Kram
Nochmal, kann man das immer nicht merken
Example please
Hier
Rule for first name blablabla
Okay, also wir erstellen
Mal ein paar Fake Autos
Rule for
So mit was fangen wir an
Fahrzeug ID
So und das war jetzt Fake
Genau, F
So Fahrzeug ID
Ist ein Random String
Also, ach ne vielleicht wir brauchen
Irgendeine Commerce
Commerce klingt gut, was haben wir da
Price
Color, Product
Also nur mal zur Erklärung
Was das macht ist, ich zeig euch das mal schnell
EAN
Ja wunderbar, ich zeig
Euch das mal schnell und zwar
Ich kann jetzt
Wir machen jetzt mal hier
Ein Return rein
Das es nicht abkackt, so ich mach jetzt mal hier
Ne Schleife
Generate 15
Autos
Jetzt werdet ihr nämlich
Sehen, dass
Jedes dieser Autos
Eine Fake ID hat
Guckt, das ist jetzt
Randomized, wenn man keine echten Daten
Hat, aber Daten für sein Frontend braucht
Das man irgendwas anzeigen kann und
Gescheit machen kann, ist diese Fake Library
Wirklich wunderbar, das ist ganz
Sehr sehr praktisch das Ding
Das hat auch ziemlich viele Sachen mit eingebaut
Zum Beispiel, wenn
Ihr, ich glaub Internet ist es
Wenn ihr
Colors, E-Mails
MAC-Adressen, Randomized Passwörter
Also nicht zum Verwenden, sondern
Für Testfängen
Protokoll Domains und alles mögliche
User Agents, kann das alles erstellen
Anhand von der internen Daten
Eingebauten
Fake Datenbank
Dann hat man halbwegs echt aussehende Objekte
Wie bestimmt man da ein eigenes
Pattern, wahrscheinlich
Falls das geht
So, also
Weiter gehts, geh mal weg
Als nächstes brauchen
Wir
Den Breitengrad
Wie faket man am besten
Einen Breitengrad, Leute
Haben die sowas wie Location, ok
Ah ne
Wie faket man einen Breitengrad
Rant
Ok, ähm
Latitude, Longitude
Äh
Valid Range
Minus 90
Bis 90
Für
Den Breitengrad
Ok, dann machen wir das ganz einfach, dann sage ich einfach
Random, Random Int
Random Int von
Minus
Minus 90 bis 90
Landen wir zwar irgendwo im Meer
Aber wie gesagt, das sind Fake Daten
Also ist das nicht wirklich relevant
So, und dann machen wir jetzt noch den Breitengrad
Der Breitengrad
Wird was, 180 bis
Minus 180
Bis 180
So, als nächstes
Ich kann heute echt nicht Tim
So, ich kopiere mir das gerade mal
Als nächstes brauchen wir noch dann
Also Langbreit haben wir
Das Jahr
Oder das Model
Ja ne, das Jahr
Kann das Jahre
Irgendwie Date, kann das Jahre randomisieren
Gescheit
Vielleicht den Address
Du meinst die Locations, vielleicht hat er sowas schon
Ah, ah, ne
Ach hier, alter
Ich hätte das gar nicht selbst machen müssen
Hä
Alter
Pog, HiIQ Chat
Der Chat hat wieder zugeschlagen
Hier, guckt euch das mal an
Einfach nur
Biggest Brain ever, hier der Chat auf
Twitch
Also, dann gehen wir hier unter Address
Address
Jawoll
Denkgrad, Breitengrad
So, ja
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich unter Date irgendwo
Sein, vermutlich
Ähm, Acrolynx
Kennst du die Library
Oder war das einfach nur
Lucky Guess
So, Date
Wie
Wie kriege ich jetzt hier
Ein Herstellerjahr raus
Was ist denn das hier, Pass
Ahja
Von jetzt, 20 Jahre zurück
Ne, ist doch auch wunderbar
Geraten
Und jetzt 20 Jahre zurück
Wunderbar
Gut
Jetzt hab ich das
Warum ist das in Long
Eigentlich reicht
So
Und als letztes müssen wir vom Auto noch
Faken
Das Model
Da hab ich aber schon ne Idee für
Was ist das
Ne, ist eigentlich gut
Da hab ich schon ne Idee für
Commerce
Und sagen sowas wie
Produkt
Produkt, was haben wir sonst noch
Produkt Name, Produkt Name, klingt gut
So, guckt und jetzt können wir
Fake Autos
Generaten, ich zeig euch das mal schnell
Äh
Machen wir den Rekord raus, dann rentet er das
Auch ordentlich
Jetzt kriegen wir 15 Fake Autos
Hier
Unbranded Fresh Ball
Alles klar
Also das sind meine Automodelle
Alles klar, Generic Fresh Hat
Rustic Frozen Towels
Unbranded Frozen Tuner
Das sind perfekte Namen für Autos, ich glaube so
Soll
Handmade Steel Pants
Das so sollten Autos
Unbedingt heißen, so, also wir haben ein ordentliches
Herstellungsjahr
Und auch ein Standort
Und ne Fahrzeug ID
Ja das passt, das ist gut
So, dann copy paste ich mir
Den Kram hier jetzt mal, dann brauchen wir nämlich noch
Das gleiche für Account
Für den Account, so
Account soll gefaked werden
Der User
User zu faken
Müsste eigentlich relativ
Einfach sein, dann nehmen wir nämlich eine E-Mail
Adresse
Internet, Mail, E-Mail
Perfekt, so
Als nächstes haben wir
Brand
Brand gibt Random
Pick
Random
Was von
Diesem E-Namen, dann haben wir noch
Ne Region, also quasi
Welche AP-Endpunkte der
Verwenden soll, Pick Random
From Region
Dann als nächstes
Brauchen wir noch Cars
Ja gut das ich das zuerst gemacht hab
Da brauchen wir jetzt nämlich
Car
Generate
Ist das richtig?
Ich glaub
Ja doch ich glaub schon
Generate between
Die müssen ja nicht immer gleich viele Autos haben
Die haben
Eins bis fünf
Autos
Was ist hier verkehrt?
Was ist hier falsch dran?
Achso, das ist Region Info, das ist auch verkehrt
You connect Region muss es sein
So
Und dann brauchen wir als letztes noch
Eine Random
UID
Das gibt es bestimmt auch irgendwo
Unter Random
Gut
So ich würde sagen
Das war es
Wir können noch
Hinzufügen für zuletzt aktualisiert
Updated
At Random
Date
Brauchen wir
Setz die immer auf null
Die randomize die nicht
Ich glaub man muss sagen
Guid
Das geht dann glaube ich
Ach ne meinst du ja
Dann hast du recht
Date
Für Updated
Between
Klingt gut
DateTime
Now
Und DateTime
Minus
60 Minuten
Das war es
Jetzt kriegen wir
Account
Nennen wir das mal
Car Faker
Account Faker
Jetzt können wir Random Accounts erstellen
Wir müssen noch eine Sache machen
Das ist alles required
Alles required
Die Liste kann ruhig leer sein
Das ist auch okay
Alles required required required
Das ich mir sicher sein kann
Das ist nicht leer
Required required required
Okay nice
Jetzt haben wir jede Menge Fake Daten
Dann lasst uns doch mal gucken ob das funktioniert
Wir machen jetzt noch eine
Ich hab kein Bock
Sqlite oder irgendeine Datenbank anzubinden
Wir machen jetzt eine Fake Datenbank
Public Class
Fake Database
Und die kriegt genau
Die kriegt genau ein
Public Static
Public Static Feld
Keine Ahnung
Accounts
Wunderbar Accounts
Ach Quatsch das soll Accounts heißen
Das soll eine Liste sein
Mit Uconnect
Ganz toll
Okay
Und da schreiben wir jetzt Fake Daten rein
Fake
Fake Database
Accounts
Clash
Account Faker
Generate
Between
Eins und Acht
So perfekt
So und das geben wir jetzt hier zurück
In der Response
Und dann können wir uns auch gleich schon mal was im Webinterface
Anzeigen lassen und gucken ob das funktioniert
Dachten
Dachte das verdammte Spiel
Page
Ich war natürlich schlau und hab direkt hier
Mein
Api Fetchen rausgeschmissen
Gut dann gucken wir mal
Was da so passiert
Ich krieg doch schon eine Antwort
Mit Autos
Drinne
Okay dann machen wir jetzt hier was
Let Accounts
Gleich leeres Array
Um keine Map als Datenbank
Mache ich dann sobald ich es brauche
So Let Accounts
Wir müssen mal eins noch machen
Mal gucken ob das ordentliches
Json ist
Was da zurückkommt
Warum ist denn das
Achso ich setze das ja nur einmalig
Dann ist klar starten wir nochmal neu
Ja guck mal jetzt sind es 6
6 Accounts
Mit insgesamt keine Ahnung
8 Autos oder so der Typ da hat Geld
Auf jeden Fall
Der Typ hat Kohle
Der schwimmt im Geld sozusagen
Accounts
Gleich diesen ganzen Schrott
Hier gut
Accountcard
So wir brauchen eine Schleife
Wir brauchen eine Schleife
Warum Backend nicht auch ins Welt
Weil das ein Frontend wird
Für ein Home Assistant Addon
Was in .NET entwickelt ist
Also macht das relativ wenig Sinn
Weil dann müsste ich die ganze Funktionalität
Neu in Javascript bauen
Wo ich ernsthaft überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe
Aber wenn man das neu macht
Könnte man sich das tatsächlich überlegen
Ob man das Backend nicht auch
Vollstacks Weltkit macht
So also
Wir brauchen eine Schleife
Wie ging das nochmal
Ne
Ach Gott Schleife ins Welt
So
Each
Accounts
As Accounts
Oder in Rust
Im Ehebüro mit eurem Scheiß Rust
Alter
Ok wird schon mal angelegt
Was machst du gerade
Ich baue ein Webinterface
Für mein Home Assistant Addon
Sodass man das erstens besser Standalone
Bauen kann und zweitens
Weil ich nicht hinkomme mit den Konfig Möglichkeiten
Die das eingebaute
Home Assistant Konfig Dialog Ding bietet
Zum Beispiel mehrere Accounts
Hier drinnen
Anzulegen
Und außerdem habe ich auch wieder Bock
Auf ein bisschen Frontend Stells
Ich finde mittlerweile Backend
Fandest du das irgendwann mal gut
Oder fandest du schon immer Kacke
Und mittlerweile auch
So
Jetzt stehe ich
Ein bisschen auf dem Schlauch
Wie ging das nochmal
Parameter an Komponenten übergeben
Warum hängt das hier so in der Luft
Äh
Oh
Da fehlt das öffnende Skript
Bisschen kaputt
Äh
Einfach nur Let, ne Export
Export Let genau
Export Let Account
So
Dann zeigen wir hier schon mal was an
Also Leute die
Cars Length
Das sollte ja dann ein Array sein
Achso Moment da ist ja noch gar nichts drin
Seck
Ähm
Ich zeige hier einfach mal den Account kurz an
Undefined
So und jetzt kann ich hier glaube ich
Account übergeben
True
Ist der Account
Account is true
Ne Moment ich muss so machen ich muss glaube ich Klammern machen
Ah Object
Object schon besser
Es laggt wirklich
Twitch ist gerade ein bisschen am abkacken
Also bei mir oh es hat tatsächlich ein paar Frames
Gedroppt
Aber
Der Fiat Champ wird ne Webanwendung
Der Fiat Champ wird nicht wirklich ne Webanwendung
Das ist ein Konfig Frontend dafür
Weil das Home Assistant
Das in Home Assistant eingebaute nicht genug Möglichkeiten gibt
Außerdem habe ich Bock auf ein bisschen Frontend
So Account Object
Okay
Passt
Lasst mal kurz gucken
Kann ich jetzt hier sowas machen wie Cars
Ja und jetzt sowas wie Length
Okay funktioniert
Okay also
Anzahl von Autos
2 Stück, 3 Stück, 1
3, 5
Der hat aber viele Autos hier
So dann lassen wir uns jetzt hier noch den Namen anzeigen
Account
Ich glaube User habe ich das genannt
Ach Moment
Ne nicht da so ein Blödsinn
Der Accounter kommt weg
Und hier oben
Hier oben kommt
Account User hin
Britgette 0
Holley 49
Elisio Weber 43
Hat 5 Autos
Alter krasser Dude
Hier oben kommt Brand
Account User
Brand
Wow
Also da sollte jetzt sowas wie Fiat stehen
Da steht aber nur 4 und 0
Nice
Ähm
Das liegt
Daran
Jetzt kann ich euch zeigen woran das liegt
Weil der Autohersteller
Ist ein E-Namen
Und standardmäßig serialisiert der
Den E-Namen
Wohl mit
Guckt mal hier
Das ist 4, 4 wäre dann quasi
Ein Dodge
Das ist natürlich bescheuert
Dass der den E-Namen serialisiert als Int
Wie bringt man dem denn bei
Dass der
Den E-Namen gefälligst als
String serialisieren soll
Weil das ist das erste Mal
Premiere Leute für mich
Das ich ein Projekt mit System Json
Oder System Text
Und nicht mit
Newtonsoft Json
E-Namen
Zu String
Json String E-Namen Converter Class
Stackoverflow weiß wieder Bescheid
Kein C++
C++ Rewrite
Das hebe ich mir auf
Das wird dann dein Spezialauftrag
Sobald C++ 2023 draußen ist
Für VIP Status
Im Chat
Csharp kann kein E-Namen Value ausgeben
Doch
Aber der Json Serializer
Alter das ist doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst hier oder
Was wollen die von mir
So what the
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst oder
Alter
Haben die hier ein Beispiel für
Was ist mit der Microsoft Seite wieder los
Mann
Warum sieht die Microsoft Seite so kacke aus
Theme
Dark okay gut
Wie macht man das denn
Serializing
E-Names
Json Serializer
Converters
Wie mach ich das
Global
Es scheint
Ah
Services
Add Json Options
Builder
Services
Add
Geil
Nice
Was so schwer kann das denn sein
Das ist bestimmt in irgendeinem Nougat Package
Wahrscheinlich
Nee
Was ist das
Configure HTTP Json Options
Haben die das umbenannt
Add Json Options
War einfach nicht
High IQ genug hat sich Microsoft gedacht
Hoffentlich ist das auch das richtige
Options
Serializer
Serializer Options
Converters
Kommt sich ja fast vor wie ein Java
Hier
Und jetzt
Json String
E-Namen Converter
Meine Güte
Mehr Java in nicht Java geht ja kaum noch
Okay
Guck mal
Jawohl
Er hat es gecheckt
Jeep Ram
Alfa Romeo Ram
Okay
Konstanz
Drei Autos, drei Jeeps
Let's go
Easy
Gut
Dann können wir das nochmal abdecken
Hab ich überhaupt ein Feld für Intervall
Scheiß drauf
Brauch ich eh nicht
So Cars
Updated
Das brauchen wir aber
Ja perfekt
Das kann jeder instant lesen
Ich glaube das ging einfach
Date
DateTime
Ups
Ah
Bin ja auch blöd
Muss so
Muss geklammert sein
Ja noch viel lesbarer
Noch viel besser
To local
Local
Ach man
Date Sachen in Javascript
To
Meine Fresse Alter
Javascript Date
Hä der Autocomplete das überhaupt nicht richtig
New Date
Autocomplete
Ist mein Autocomplete abgekackt
Kann das sein
Ja mein Autocomplete ist abgeschissen
Gut Job Microsoft
Perfekt
Exzellent
Ja jetzt funktioniert es auch wieder
Äh
Local
To local
String
Und ich glaube dann muss man noch
DE oder sowas angeben
Das sieht doch schonmal ein bisschen besser aus
Update 5.8
18.46
Das ist random
Okay
DE DE ist besser
Auch gut wenn ihr das sagt Chat
So
Also
Das sieht jetzt schonmal ganz brauchbar aus
Nur diese Lade Dinger
Die stimmen ja hinten und vorne nicht
Das heißt wir machen mal
Das weg würde ich sagen
Wir machen das mal fest
An einem weiteren Feld und zwar
Machen wir mal sowas wie
Updated oder oder
Is updating
Is refreshing oder irgendwie
Sowas in der Richtung
Ist das die Sharp im Frontend
Das ist Javascript im Frontend und die Sharp im Backend
Die Sharp im Frontend
Wäre ja mit Blazer mittlerweile auch möglich
Aber irgendwie
Ist bei mir der Funke noch nicht übergesprungen
Was Blazer angeht
So machen wir mal sowas wie hier
Bool
Und dann irgendwie nennen wir es mal
Is
Oder refresh
In progress
Oder ich glaube
Offiziell sagen die ja man soll das mit
Is anfangen alle Boolean Werte
Is refresh in
Progress
So das setzen wir jetzt mal auf
True
Nee Moment setzen wir nicht auf True
Wir setzen das auf
Wir lassen das faken
Für den Account
Lass das auch ordentlich
Refresh
Is refresh in progress
Random
Bool
Jawoll
Gut
Es wird ein Webinterface gebaut
Für mein Home Assistant Addon
Wo man Sachen von seinem
Also Werte von seinem Elektroauto auslesen kann
Weil sich manche Leute gewünscht haben dass man das besser Standalone
Benutzen kann
Im Krankenhaus
Is Batman
Frontend Hackermans
Genau das Richtige
Blazer Wasm
Hab ich in meinem IHK Abschlussprojekt gemacht
Kommt wie Fabian
Mein
Welches E-Auto hast du denn
Und wie machst du das Auslesen
Ich hab ein Fiat 500 E
Und das Auslesen mach ich über die nicht offizielle
API von Fiat
Die ich teilweise
Reverse Engineert hab
Mit nem Proxy aus der App
Und mir Implementierungen von anderen
Angeguckt hab die das gleiche gemacht haben
Um rauszubekommen
Welche Endpunkte die App so aufruft
Es gibt keine offizielle
API von Fiat das halt ist doofe dabei
So
Oh was ist jetzt hier
Fehler warum
Ja
Dankeschön Alfred
So ist richtig
Sicher kannst du auch
Instagram Accounts hacken
So
Und sind wir stehen geblieben
Drucker reparieren ist meine
Spezialität
Kennt ihr noch irgendwie
Kennt ihr noch dieses
Schweizer Video
Sorry Leute ich darf mich jetzt nicht sidetracken lassen
Schweizer
Drucker repariert Drucker
Kennt das noch irgend
Kennt das noch irgendjemand
Vor allem Hallo
Sie haben Probleme
Richtiges Boomer
Das ist 15 Jahre alt
Passt mal auf
Wie er den Drucker repariert
Also ja keine Gewalt
Sonst
Brecht das ab
Das ist so dumm
Ok Stopp
Nicht sidetracken lassen
Was wollte ich jetzt machen
Suche einfach Schweizer repariert Drucker
Oder sowas
Ist Refresh in Progress
Wollte ich abfragen
Wenn er Refresh in Progress ist
Sollte da oben das angezeigt werden
Gucken wir mal
Account
Is
Refresh in Progress
False
True
Ok das scheint zu funktionieren
Dann müssen wir jetzt abhängig davon
Anzeigen
Class
Visible
Ist Refresh in Progress
Wenn das in Progress ist
Wenn es nicht in Progress ist
Dann will ich
Sagen dass das in
Visible sein soll
Hey
Ok
Das ist gut
Nur die wo aktuell gerade Refresh wird
Haben so einen Kringel jetzt
Sehr schön
Der BoGusikowski36
Der kann sich nur ein Auto
Leisten
Das ist auch schon mal besser
Da kann man jetzt schon mal was mit anfangen
So
Und jetzt
Ok
Jetzt wird es ein bisschen kompliziert
Cringe
Wenn er nur eins hat
Ganz
Geringverdiener
Soll sich mal hier an
Sahari71 ein Beispiel nehmen
Der hat aber auch nur 3
Aber nur 3 Fiats
Aber Invisible ist doch immer aktiv
Ja das ist Absicht
Wenn ich das hier rausnehme
Guck mal
Dann stimmt das
Alignment von der Überschrift nicht
So ist es immer aktiv
Und sonst ist halt ein unsichtbares Element da
Leute
Jetzt wird es advanced
Wir müssen das irgendwie
Automatisch
Wir müssen das irgendwie dazu bringen
Dass es automatisch
Updated
Wir brauchen jetzt Websockets
Oder sowas in der Richtung
Weil
Wir bauen das jetzt mal
Wir tun jetzt mal so
Als wäre schon das restliche
Addon im Hintergrund aktiv
Und Refresh
Diese ganzen Sachen
Also
Ja Websocket oder
Wir könnten auch einfach einmal in der Sekunde
Pollen oder so
Das würde auch funktionieren
Aber ich glaube wir machen Websocket
Signal R
Weil es ja Microsoft Shit ist
Und die mögen plain Websockets
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht so sehr
CraftQL habe ich das letzte Mal auch verwendet
Im letzten bisschen größeren Projekt
Ist auch eine nice Sache mit Hot Chocolate
Nennt sich die Library
Für ASP.NET Core
Aber in dem Fall glaube ich ist das ausreichend
Wenn wir ein bisschen Websockets machen
Okay also machen wir mal
Public Class Refresher
Heißt das Ding jetzt
Passendere Name ein Background Service
So wir faken jetzt mal
Dass im Hintergrund
Ein bisschen was passiert
Als würde der im Hintergrund refreshen
Wir tun jetzt einfach mal so
Also
Not stopping
Token is
Cancellation requested
Return task
Task completed
So
Lass uns das mal überlegen
Wir machen jetzt eine Schleife
Über alle Accounts
Data
Fake Database
Über alle Accounts
Und
Dann setzen wir einfach
Den
IsRefreshingInProgress
Auf Random
Gibt das eigentlich sowas wie RandomBool
Ne das wäre ja auch zu einfach
Wir können auch Faker benutzen
Random
Shared
Halt ein Int meinetwegen
Int
MaxValue
Ist das
Inclusive oder Exclusive
ExclusiveUpperBound
Ich denke mal MinValue
Ist 0 machen wir mal lieber so
Okay also wenn das gleich
1 ist
Dann setzen wir das da drauf
Okay
Oh Leute wir haben eine Endlos
Schleife fabriziert wir sollten vielleicht mal
Einen kleinen Sleep noch einbauen
Pass mal auf guck mal
Guck mal meine CPU Last
Ist ein Kern komplett
Ich glaube das ist gerade ziemlich am abkacken
Schon
Okay
Also dann
AwaitTaskDelay
Keine Ahnung
1 Sekunde oder so 100 Millisekunden
Async
Perfekt
Zack
Daten
Ach jetzt brauche ich das ja gar nicht mehr
Und jetzt sollte sich im Hintergrund
Wenn ich refreshe
Habt ihr das gesehen
Es ändert sich ab und zu mal was
Oder nicht
Moment ich update ja noch gar nichts automatisch
Das wichtigste habe ich ja vergessen
Ich update ja noch gar nichts automatisch
Okay wir können das
Wir machen das testweise
Einmal wir sagen
SetIntervall
Alle 100 Millisekunden
Neu abrufen okay
Funktioniert das nicht
Warum geht das nicht
Ich starte den Background Service noch gar nicht
Deswegen geht das nicht
Ich starte den Krempel ja noch gar nicht
Okay
Ja hier
Ich muss den ja noch starten
Das ging
Bilder
Services
Ads
Posted Service
Refresher
Ey wo kommt die 1
Hier her gerade
Ach hier von der ID okay dann funktioniert das mit dem
Refresh
Ja seht ihr guck
Es updatet vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel des Guten
Aber es funktioniert prinzipiell
Ja
Also prinzipiell updatet er
Man zwar alle 100 Millisekunden
Ist zwar extrem bescheuert
Aber immerhin
Na das klappt ganz gut
Gut dann würde ich sagen
Machen wir das ganze jetzt mal interaktiv
Das was Echtzeit aktualisiert
Die der APN Punkt
Kommt weg
So jetzt jetzt muss ich mal überlegen
Es ist lange her das ich mit Signal A was gemacht
Hab
Also ist das hier eigentlich soweit okay
Denke schon
Wir stellen das mal hoch auf
Komm ich stelle es mal auf eine Sekunde hoch wir wollen es mal nicht übertreiben
Ah Leute ich habe noch eine andere Idee
Eins probieren wir noch
Eins machen wir noch
Um das zu gucken ob das
So wie ich mir das vorstelle auch gut
Funktioniert
Und zwar
Legt sich wieder ein hier
Gut und zwar
Wir stellen jetzt noch ein
Das wenn
Der Flash in Progress
Zurückgesetzt wird
Das dann Updated
Eine Zeit bekommt
Ob das die eleganteste Art und Weise ist
Das zu machen
Ist das eigentlich Debian
Nein das ist Archlinux by the way
Die beste Distribution ever
Und sobald du die verwendest musst du auch der Welt immer erzählen
Dass du die jetzt verwendest
Ganz essentiell wichtig
Bester Bestandteil von jedem
Archlinux User
Wenn jeder Veganer erzählt dass er Veganer ist
Muss dir auch jeder Archlinux User erzählen
Dass er Archlinux used
Ich use übrigens auch
Arch by the way
Hier Arch by the way
Du used auch Arch seit 2 Wochen
Beste
Wer used noch Arch chat
Ich bin enttäuscht von euch
Dass ihr das nicht schon öfters erzählt habt
Wenn ihr Archlinux used
Alle 5 Minuten muss das erwähnt werden
So ist das gut
So wir stellen das
Wir stellen das jetzt mal um
Und zwar sagen wir Property with Backlog Field
Get
Das ist ok
Set
Wenn der Value
Gesetzt wird dann
If
Ups
Wenn das gerade True ist
Und der Value wird gesetzt auf
False
IsRefreshIn
Ne
Dann
Updated at
DateTimeNow
Bin mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
Es sollte jetzt wenn das klappt
Oh
Ahja
Semikolon vergessen der Klassiker
Der Error geht gut rein
Ach guck mal seht ihr
Der aktualisiert
Pass auf sobald das wieder
Ja
Also Updated
Fast wie in der echten Datenbank
Was ist der Befehl
Du meinst das hier
Neofetch
Es gibt auch noch Screenfetch glaube
Beste
Ja vielleicht ein bisschen
Ja wenn man weiß
Dass du das da schonmal erkannt hast
Dass es ein dicker Typ ist
Ja
Gut
Also hätten wir das auch
Wir nähern uns
Dem ordentlich funktionierenden
WebUI
Also das finde ich schonmal ganz gut
So wie das jetzt funktioniert
Ich meine wir können noch nichts
Adden wir können noch nichts löschen
Ist alles ziemlich
Aber das wird
So
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen
Stoppen wir das erstmal
Also jetzt müssen wir einbauen
Dass das ganze echtzeitfähig wird
Also sprich
Dass es instant refresh
Sobald sich was tut
Also bauen wir Signal A ein
Habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr benutzt
Signal R
So und wenn ich das richtig
Im Kopf habe dann muss man hier
So was sagen wie
Builder Service
Signal R
Und dann muss man hier
Unten noch sagen
Map Use oder Map
Map
Okay was
Oder vielleicht doch
Signal R
Getting Started
ASP.NET
Map Hub
Was haben sie sich da wieder ausgedacht
Map
Hub
Ach stimmt brauche ich ja noch
Ich muss ja noch
Ein Hub anlegen
Der mir
Das Websocket
Geschiss handelt
Jaja ich erinnere mich
Es ist wirklich schon eine ganze Weile her wo ich das zuletzt benutzt habe
Okay
Da brauchen wir jetzt eine Klasse
Die heißt ich lege meinen eigenen Ordner an
Sonst wird es langsam echt zu unübersichtlich
Okay
Das Ding heißt
Message Hub
Ich versuche mir was anderes auszudenken
Perfekt
Message Hub
So
Ah und jetzt brauchen wir noch angeben
Unter Slash Hub ist es erreichbar
Das muss abgeleitet werden
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe
Von Hub
Jetzt sollte es zumindest mal wieder kompilieren
Okay nice
Boah das ist lange her
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal
Ich glaube es gibt
Sowas wie On Connect genau
So und da konnte man jetzt
Sagen On Connect
Schick denen einfach mal
Alle Daten die du hast das ist die einfachste Variante
Jetzt wie wir das machen können
Also this
Context
User
Connection ID klingt schon mal gut
Clients
Nee
Caller
Send
Okay das ist richtig
So ist Send Caller
So und der kriegt jetzt
Das geschickt
Das heißt
Auf dem Frontend brauchen wir eine Methode dafür
Das heißt Update
Und der kriegt Fake Database Accounts
Geschickt
Gutes
So
Das sollte eigentlich schon reichen
Starten wir mal das Frontend
Das updatet
Ein bisschen zu viel
Deswegen schmeißen wir
Den Grämpel einfach mal raus
Das brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr
Und hier schmeißen wir den
AP Endpunkt vorbei
Ganz ehrlich
Den kommentieren wir mal aus
Wir brauchen noch ein Post und Delete
Gut
Und jetzt
Gibt es auch ein Getting Started
Für Frontend
Microsoft Signal
Our latest brauchen wir
Okay
NPM install
Microsoft Signal
Our latest
NPM
Run Dev
Gut
Wie baut man den Shit denn jetzt ein
Er
Kompiliert erstmal
Ganz schön
Ja abseite
Startet gar nicht mehr
So weit sind wir schon
Webanwendung für den Browser
Erstmal eine halbe Stunde
Okay
Import
Microsoft
Und was kann man da jetzt importieren
Okay Zeug
Das ist schon mal richtig
Und wie funktioniert der Grämpel im Frontend
Nochmal
Hier
Okay gut das brauchen wir
Das brauchen wir
Ein Signal
Ich kann das doch bestimmt
Hub
Connection Builder
Das ist wieder so Microsoft
Gedöns
Okay und wir wollen
Connecten zu Hub
Und jetzt sagen wir Connection
Start
Wow
Alter
Gut
Achso Moment das ist ja auch falsch
Ich will ja gar nicht nach Slash Hub
Ich will nach HTTP
Doppel Slash Local Host
Port 5050
Slash Hub
Falscher
Was ist das jetzt schon wieder
Access to Fetch
Ich hab Kors und
Konsorten hab ich doch eingeschaltet
Hör mal ein bisschen Wupp Wupp Wupp an
Wupp Wupp Wupp
Okay
Ähm
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen
From Origin has been blocked by Kors Policy
Blablabla
What
Access Control
Allow Origin
Must not be
Wildcard
Ich hab das doch gerade auf Wildcard
Gesetzt das einfach alles funktioniert
Mensch Microsoft Alter
Erzähl mir woran es liegt
Ja
Beste Stackoverflow weiß Bescheid
Was muss ich machen
Aha
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen muss ich
Bei Start without Credentials reinpasten
Geht nicht
Nice GG
Du darfst nicht Wildcard nehmen
Ich will ja Wildcard nehmen
Okay was haben wir hier noch
Set is Origin
Allowed
Kein Ding kann ich auch machen
Wir machen
Wildes Copy Paste
Bis es funktioniert das bin ich gut drin
Was
Geht es jetzt
Scheiße Alter was das
Ähm
Scheint ja wieder
Absoluter Fiveheader Shit zu sein
Microsoft wie das funktioniert
Ja
Mensch Alter
Erzähl mir wie es geht
Okay
You either need to specify the origins
Or remove allow credentials
And set with credentials to false on the client
Okay
With credentials
With all
Hä
Hier oder was
Die Connection Options tatsächlich
Meine Güte da wäre ich im Leben
Nicht drauf gekommen
With Credentials gleich
False
Jetzt funktioniert es
Alter schwere Geburt Microsoft
Okay
Jetzt verbinden wir uns mit
Der Signal mit dem
Mit dem
Websocket auf Server Seite
Und jetzt müssen wir on
Update
Hab ich ja gesagt rufen wir auf
Data
Loggen wir das Ganze mal
Guck mal passt
Sobald ich mich connecte kriege ich den Kram ausgespuckt
Sehr schön
Ich muss das aber noch updaten
Und zwar jedes Mal
Wenn
Moment jedes Mal
Wenn das hier durchläuft in der Sekunde
Will ich ja auch Bescheid sagen
Achtung es gibt neue Daten
Das ging wenn ich das richtig im Kopf
Habe ich glaube wir brauchen
Ein
Habkontext
Und dann
Message
Okay und jetzt kann man hier sagen
Habkontext
Clients
Warum nicht
Ach all
Fake database
Ach ne ich muss ja noch sagen
Wohin
Update
Await
So und jetzt sollte der mir alle
Warum hängt denn das jetzt
Was habe ich falsch gemacht
Warum hängt es
Ach das kann sein dass er wegen den ganzen
Websocket Connections hängt
Guck hier closed
Ja
Der braucht ein bisschen bis er sich beendet
Okay der sollte jetzt alle Sekunde
Updates hier rein schicken
Macht er
Alle Sekunde kommen Updates
Also ich meine das ist jetzt natürlich nur
Nein nein du bist nicht der einzige
Bei ganz vielen ist Twitch gerade ziemlich im Arsch
Guck mal
Das funktioniert er updatet jetzt einmal in der Sekunde
Wobei das einmal in der Sekunde updaten
Jetzt ja auch nur ein
Serverseitiger Task ist
In Zukunft wird das updaten
Wenn es dann dann einfach so ist
Und nicht einmal in der Sekunde alle
Das ist ja gerade Sinn und Zweck der Sache von so einer Echtzeit
Bidirektionalen Verbindung
Zwischen Client und Server
So
Jetzt muss ich die Daten
Ja natürlich noch setzen
Jedes Mal
Connection
Accounts
Gleich Data
Wenn ich hier nichts setze ist es leer
Okay das ist gut
Das gefällt mir
Ja
Wir können das glaube ich auch ein bisschen runterschrauben
Auf
5 Sekunden
Reconnected auch ich glaube das muss man
Angeben hier irgendwo
Automatic Reconnect
Ja nice
Theoretisch kannst du das Update auch pro
Account Komponent ja so wird das in Zukunft auch sein
Die Accounts haben unterschiedliche
Intervalle
Wie die
Abgefragt werden pro Auto geht nicht
Du kannst immer nur ein Account aktualisieren
Das geht nicht anders
Du kannst nicht explizit ein Auto aktualisieren
Aber die können unterschiedliche
Intervalle haben von keine Ahnung von 5
Minuten bis 30 Minuten je nachdem
Muss auch gucken dass man nicht ins Rate Limit läuft
Das ist zwar recht hoch aber
Nicht so hoch dass man alle 30 Sekunden
Da neue Daten sich holen kann
Okay
Das ist doch jetzt schon mal
Gar nicht so schlecht
Guck mal das Updates schön dynamisch
Im Frontend hier
Immer wenn es Updates zeigt es
Einen Kreis an
Wenn es fertig Updaten ist aktualisiert
Er die Zeit
Hat er gerade die Zeit aktualisiert
Moment der aktualisiert
Bei Zeit beim starten
Ja ne das
Dann habe ich da
Mist eingestellt
Der soll die Zeit aktualisieren
So eigentlich richtig
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht
Wenn
Aktuell das auf True steht und
Der neu gesetzte Value ist
Dann soll
Das aktualisieren also er soll auf jeden Fall
Erst beim
Beim ausschalten sollte der eigentlich
Erst aktualisieren
Naja
Verstehe ich
Irgendwas in meiner Logik
Aber gut ich meine gibt es Schlimmeres
Ich hätte das eigentlich gedacht
Das müsste passen
Verstehe ich nicht
Die Zeit wird nicht aktualisiert
Die Zeit wird aktualisiert wenn er startet
Nicht wenn er
Nicht wenn er fertig ist
Twitch ist so instabil
Ja ich sehe es hier
Ganz viele Leute immer raus in Massen
Und dann sind auf einmal wieder alle da
Twitch ist gerade am abkacken
Aber an mir liegt es nicht
Ich kann da nichts machen
Ok
Jetzt verwenden wir mal ein
Svelte Feature und zwar legen wir
Einen Store an
Dort ist dann auch AWS
Wir legen jetzt einen Store an
Damit wir diese
Refresh Logik
Ein bisschen auslagern können
Und zwar
Machen wir jetzt einen Svelte Store
Den legen wir mal hier an
Der heißt Theta Store
Mir fällt gerade nichts gescheites ein
Ähm
Svelte Store
Einmal ein
Example Writable Store
Ja
Was muss ich importieren? Store
Ja Writable
So das heißt jetzt
Theta Store
Besser Name überhaupt
So Theta Store
Und jetzt packe ich die ganze
Connection Geschichte
Kommt jetzt hier weg bei Accounts
Kommt jetzt hier rein
Moment
Der
Das muss auch noch da rein
So gut
With Credentials Falls
Build on Update
Das kann ich mir sparen hier
Ok
Und jetzt muss ich noch einstellen
Was passiert wenn es geupdated
Wird und zwar
Brauchen wir jetzt Theta Store
Set
Theta
Wobei ich kann
Doch die ganze, warum mache ich da eigentlich
Semicolons bei, Leute
Ist es jetzt noch empfohlen bei Javascript
Semicolons zu machen oder nicht?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht mehr
Ich mache es immer automatisch
Weil
Ich finde es total anstrengend
Wenn ich das
In C Sharp machen muss und in Javascript nicht
Da komme ich immer durcheinander
Schaden kann es nicht
Theta Store
Ok Import
Hallo
Import
Theta Store
Das hätte ich auch noch rüber kopieren müssen
Ah man Frontend
So
Ok funktioniert
So und jetzt kann ich das hier ersetzen
Die Accounts kann ich ersetzen durch
Theta Store
Ups
Was mache ich denn hier
Theta Store
Ja, nice, funktioniert
So und er sollte jetzt auch immer schön im Hintergrund
Visualisieren
Oh, fehlen die Default-Werte
Achso
Writable 0, das muss ein Array sein
Gut, nice, funktioniert
Äh, ach nee
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt serialisiert er
Die E-Names wieder falsch
Bruce Wolf hat ein Fiat
Und keine 0
Ok, dann muss man bestimmt hier oben jetzt noch konfigurieren
Den gleichen Chip nochmal für Signal A
Gibt das sowas wie
Warte mal
Gibt das, ok, gucken wir mal
Signal A, nee
Dann ist es bestimmt hier hinten dran
Jason Protokoll
Jawoll und dann gibt es hier
Options
Wow, Microsoft
Alter, was die sich immer mit dem
Konfig-Shit da denken
Weiß ich anders
Options
Payload, ok das ist das gleiche
Ne, doch nicht
Payload Serializer Options
Natürlich, es darf ja selbstverständlich
Auch nicht gleich heißen
Wo kämen wir da hin, wenn man sich da dran
Gewöhnen könnte, wie das heißt
Gut
Gucken wir mal hier
Jetzt haben wir nur ein Auto
Was es hinzugefügt hat, aber gut
Es funktioniert, nice
Ja, sehr schön
Steht jetzt Dodge da und nicht mehr
0 oder 3 oder so
Jetzt haben wir das hier schön
Ausgelagert in den Store
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich da auch nicht
Nicht mal so viel
Rumwursten dran
So
Dann können wir uns jetzt ein bisschen auf
Die Frontend-Geschichte konzentrieren
Wie ist es denn
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich den Delete-Button
Drücke, dann passiert ja nichts
Aber eigentlich möchte ich, dass es
Deleted wird
Da müssen wir mal gucken, wie macht man
In Skeleton UI
Ein Popup
Nein
Nicht Store
Docs
Popup
Ein Model wollen wir haben
Das kommt in
Die Layout-Datei rein
Weil wir das ja global haben wollen
Ganz hier oben drüber
Ein Model ist so ein
Overlay
Jetzt weiß ich bloß nicht genau, wie man den Crample
Triggert
Ich brauche unbedingt auch
Eine Dance-Skelette, ganz wichtig
Page
Geht nicht
Ach, weil da
Typescript-Gedöns mit dabei ist
Ja, geht sofort
Nice, okay
Unser Overlay geht
Nur, dass ich eigentlich keine dancende Skelette
Haben will
Sondern
Unsere Abfrage, ja, nein
Oh, was kackt der denn hier ab
Error from
Request
Achso, der kackt ab, weil
Das Backend gerade nicht läuft
Das lasse ich mir gefallen
Das ist der Exempel
Wie konnte ich das Abfragen machen, ja, nein
Confirm
Genau, das will ich haben
Das will ich haben
Hier, gebe ihm
Moin Max
Weg damit
Please confirm
Yes
So, und das will ich jetzt haben
Wenn
Oh, ups
Das will ich haben
Wenn
Ich hier auf Delete klicke
Also
Wenn ich das Trash-Icon
Wenn ich den Button vom Trash-Icon anklicke
On, klick
Komm hier
Function
Remove
Remove Account
Jetzt einfach mal
Ja, mit der Account-ID
Oder so
Hauen wir das mal rein
Unexpected Token
Wo
Ach da
Okay, das muss man so machen
Remove Account
Das reicht eigentlich, wenn ich das so trinke
Weil die Account-ID habe ich ja hier oben
Ich muss die ID gar nicht übergeben
Remove Account
Den Account habe ich hier drinnen
Okay, das heißt, wenn ich den jetzt anklicke
Dann
Is not defined
Store
While javascript
So, wenn ich das jetzt anklicke, dann
Ja, please confirm
Genau, sind wir
Okay, also, jetzt
Müssen wir ordentlich abfragen
Eine ordentliche Abfrage machen
Delete
Account
Abfragezeichen
Wir machen hier noch Delete Account
Schreiben wir jetzt noch dahinter, welcher das ist
Delete
Account
User
So
Delete Account
Giuseppe Wildermann 82
Yahoo, yes, confirm
Okay, gut
Das sieht auch schon mal ganz brauchbar aus
Ja, es gibt einen Discord
Komfi Fabian, falls du vorhin
Subscribed hast, danke für den Sub
Ich hab die Hälfte vor lauter Hackermans
Komplett übersehen
Stream Manager
Du hast subscribed vor 17 Minuten, dankeschön
Nicht gesehen, der Alfred auch am Start
Fadel auch am Start
Ich seh dir mal
Ich war heute so im
High-Performer-Mindset unterwegs
Da hab ich gar nichts mitgekriegt
Das funktioniert schon mal ganz gut
Jetzt müssen wir uns natürlich nur überlegen
Wie wir nicht nur
Einen Pop-Up machen, dass wir das löschen
Sondern wie wir auch wirklich löschen
Weil aktuell machen wir nur
Einen Pop-Up, dass wir löschen
Okay, also
Dann würde ich sagen
Bauen wir das doch mal ein
In der Response, das nennen wir nicht
R, sondern OK
Was ist jetzt schon hier wieder verkehrt, Javascriptmann
Was ist das Problem?
Hä?
Zu viel?
If die Antwort ist OK
Dann
Müssen wir einen Fetch machen
Fetch an den APN-Punkt, den wir noch nicht haben
Gut, dass ich den APN-Punkt
Nur auskommentiert hab und den wir jetzt umbauen können
Also
APN-Punkt, nennen wir mal
Accounts
Slash ID
So und wir wollen jetzt ein Delete mappen
Allerdings wollen wir keine ID
Sondern, naja, eine GUID
Wollen wir haben, die gelöscht werden soll
Gut
Ja, wir returnen einfach immer OK
Ist mir egal
Und jetzt sagen wir Fake Database
Accounts, aha
Jetzt haben wir ein Problem
Jetzt könnte das Ding instant crashen, wenn ich nicht aufpasse
Weil
Ich lese und schreibe
In eine
Nicht-threadsichere Collection
Also jetzt machen wir das, was vorhin schon
Einer vorgeschrieben hat
Vorgeschlagen hat
Wir machen ein Dictionary draus
Das ist eine gute Idee gewesen
Und jetzt
Klappt das hier nicht, weil
Das kein Arraymer ist
Try Add
Und zwar mit der
Mit der GUID
Und dann den Account
Und dann sollte ich auch einstellen
Nein, nein, nein
Jetzt sollte ich auch einstellen, dass das eine GUID ist
Und kein String
Gut
So, wo hatten wir jetzt das Problem?
Hier unten
Achso, ah
Jetzt ist natürlich auch Account nicht mehr Account
Sondern es sind alle Values
Gut
OK
Alles klar, so, Delete
Jetzt kann ich löschen
Jetzt kann ich löschen, also
Fake Database, Accounts, Remove
Oder Try Remove
Try Remove
Den Account
Mit dieser ID
Und den Rest ist mir egal
Was ist das für ein Problem?
Was hast du für Schmerzen?
Achso, Try Remove
Nicht Try Add
Passt richtig
Try Remove
So, und jetzt
OK, es sollte jetzt schon funktionieren
Aber das automatische Refreshen
Ist mir noch ein bisschen zu lahm, passt mal auf
Es sollte, oh
Äh
Ah, es sind nicht Accounts, sondern
Die Values, alles klar
Du hast keinen Abo-Button
Debated
Cuba Libre
Dankeschön für den Sub
So, es sollte jetzt funktionieren
Allerdings noch nicht komplett
Automatisch
So, also
Ach man
Was ist das für ein Problem?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Only iterates over Array
Ist doch gut so
Reserive, danke für den Sub
Only iterates over Array
Like Objects, OK
Was
Was genau hast du jetzt für
Schmerzen?
Wie
Es geht initial einmal und danach nicht mehr
Das ergibt jetzt aber überhaupt keinen Sinn
Loggen wir mal
Was da zurückkommt beim Update
Ja, alles gut
Ah, Moment
Da kommt irgendein Shit zurück
Weil
OK, das ist, ich bin richtig dumm
Ich weiß woran es liegt
Ich gebe das doch hier einmal
Beim
Beim Updaten
OK, das müssen wir unbedingt
In irgendeine gemeinsame Methode rausziehen
Sonst werde ich das
Immer vergessen zu aktualisieren
Immer
Das hier ist das Problem, das Update
Update habe ich
Die Accounts falsch übergeben
Das muss ich irgendwie in irgendeine
Helperklasse oder so rausziehen
Das werde ich jedes Mal vergessen
Das weiß ich jetzt schon
Ja, OK, so ist nice, so ist gut
So ist Pogu
Pogu, so schauen wir mal
Delete, so ich habe
Deleted, mal gucken ob der jetzt refresht
Das muss ich noch ein bisschen schneller hinkriegen
OK, also Dennis
Dennis ist gelöscht
Nee, Dennis ist nicht
Gelöscht, habe ich da irgendwas
Vergessen
Achso, ja ich mache noch gar kein
Ich mache ja noch gar kein
Request
Ich copy paste mir das mal, weil ich die Fetch
API nicht merken kann
Async
OK, so
API
Accounts
Fetch, jetzt müssen wir einstellen
Dass wir als Methode
Kein Get nehmen wollen
Sondern
Ein Delete
Delete
Ja, müsste eigentlich jetzt so gehen
Ach shit
Not found
API Accounts, warum not found
API
Accounts ID
Ja logisch, der soll ja nicht alle löschen
Keck, wait
ID
Nee, Account
Oder
Heißt es da GUI
Leute ich muss das auf jeden Fall einheitlich nennen auf beiden Seiten
Sonst ist F
Ja
Das muss ich auf jeden Fall einheitlich nennen
Und sonst ist
Vorbei
So
Das müsste funktionieren, ich bin mal gespannt
Schauen wir mal
Mich nervt es, dass es so lange hängt jetzt beim Beenden
Das muss ich irgendwie
Schneller Verbindungen
Closen, gucken was man da mal nach Timeout gucken muss
Das ist ätzend so lange zu warten
So, Melissa, aha
Habt das gesehen
Gelöscht, das dauert jetzt kurz
Bis zum automatischen Refresh, das muss ich noch einbauen
Hat funktioniert
Können Sachen löschen
So, jetzt muss natürlich noch hier rein
An die Stelle, wo der
Wo das
Wo das gelöscht wird
In der API
Da muss jetzt eigentlich noch mal
Dieser gleiche Update
Das gleiche Update rein
Für den Client
Die an der anderen Stelle
Aber ich muss das unbedingt
Da rausziehen, jetzt habe ich schon 3 Stellen
Wo ich das anpassen muss, da denke ich
Im Leben nicht dran
Die ID noch mitgeben
Nee, das hast du vorher schon
Hast du dein
Bosch Heizungsthermostat in den Sommer-Mode
Stellen können über ZigBee? Nein, ich habe es noch nicht
Weiter ausprobiert
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
I have context
Message up
Cancellation token habe ich nicht
So
Okay, jetzt sollte es
Funktionieren, pass mal auf
Wenn ich jetzt auf löschen drücke, sollte es
Instant weg sein
Jetzt ist nur einer drin zum testen, aber okay
Passt auf und jetzt
Ach shit
Ach, ich update vor dem
Remove
Ich update vor dem Remove
Okay, das fuckt mich ja mega ab, dass es
So lange braucht immer, wir müssen das mal
Ein bisschen ordentlich machen, also
Wir brauchen jetzt sowas wie ein
Public Class
Message Hub Helper
Mir fällt wirklich gerade kein besserer Name ein
Und dieser Mist hier
Das da, kommt da rein
So, ne
Nicht da rein
I have context
Message Hub
Public
Task
Send update
Beste
So
Sonst vergesse ich, jetzt mache ich das immer verkehrt
Cancellation token haben wir nicht
An der Stelle
Dann machen wir das
Wobei, wir können es ja einfach übergeben
Cancellation token
Default
So
Send update, genau
So und
Und das injecten wir jetzt hier
Anstatt diesem komischen
Kontext
Doch sollte ich machen, Akrolyx hast du recht
Message Hub Helper
Und der andere
Kampel kommt weg
Und dann kann ich mir das hier nämlich sparen
Hab
Send update
Ja, das ist viel besser gleich
Cancellation token
Was auch
Immer, warum das hier Stopping token
Heißt und hier sollte ich es auch übergeben, ja ist schon
Besser, ok und jetzt
I have context, wo habe ich den
Kram noch, hier, dort will
Ich auch mal ein Message Hub Helper
Keine Ahnung, ich müsste das
Das müsste schon ein bisschen schönere
Namen haben
Aber mir fällt keiner ein
Helper, Helper
So
Send update
Gut
Perfekt, wieso reimt sich
Eigentlich Wooplores auf echt verdammt
Sexy Hacker-Man, das kann doch
Kein Zufall sein, da frage ich mich auch
Hat dir das Chat-GPT
Gesagt
Hier, try remove
Send update
Hab ich das sonst noch
Irgendwie, I have
Context
Heute ist mit Tippen ja wirklich schlimm
Hab context
Ne, ok das ist
Richtig, kann ich
Den hier jetzt auch
Hier injecten
Dass ich es dann hier auch nicht
Vergesse
Ich mein, man sagt ja immer
Die Klassen sollen sich
Nicht gegenseitig kennen
Aber ganz ehrlich
Scheiß drauf
Und ich muss das Ding noch registrieren
Service
Add
Dass es nur eine Klasse davon gibt
Message Hub Helper
Ich hoffe
Das geht in der Reihenfolge richtig
Ne, ich muss das auf jeden Fall
Danach registrieren oder
Oder ist es egal
Weil es eh erst
Instanziert wird danach, ich glaube es ist egal
Ich glaube die Reihenfolge ist in dem Fall sogar egal
Ok
Hub Helper send update
Allerdings nicht an alle
Diesmal, sondern
Nur an
Das
Context
Connection ID, nur hier hin
Da braucht man ein Overload
Für
String Connection ID
Hub
Clients
Krieg ich da die
Connection ID raus
Und jetzt sag ich
Send
Ok, so und ich hoffe das Scheiß
Funktioniert jetzt, ich bin
Nicht so zuversichtlich, aber
Ich wüsste jetzt auch erstmal nicht spontan
Was falsch ist
Schauen wir mal
Gucken wir mal
Ok
So jetzt sollte er instant löschen
Bam, jawoll habt ihr es gesehen
Guck mal, instant Refresh nach dem löschen
Mit
Server Response
Sehr schön, sehr gut
Alter, das fuckt mich ja ab
Dass das so lange hängt
Wie kriegen wir
Wie kriegen wir das weg
Ich muss dem irgendwie mitteilen können
Dass mein Backend shutdown
Da soll sich die Connection disconnecten
Die Connection soll sich
Disconnecten, also ich glaube in wehreren
Satz habe ich noch nie gebildet
Richtig hängen geblieben, ja wir machen sowas wie
Send, Shutdown
Ja, ich glaube das geht
Application
App
Lifetime
Und jetzt
Shutdown
Ich sag allen Clients Bescheid, dass ich
Backend Server runterfährt damit
Und das
Heißt ich warte jetzt
Drauf
Bis die
Application
Bis Application Stopping getriggert
Wird
Und wenn
Application Stopping getriggert wird
Dann rufe ich
Shutdown
Auf
Wie lange das dauert ist mir egal
Okay, das könnte tatsächlich so
Funktionieren
Bist ein Fan meiner Toilettenvideos, das ist nice
Beste, beste
Sache, die Toilettenvideos sind so
Gut, falls du das noch nicht wusstest
Die sind so gut, dass sogar ein russischer
Channel meine Klovideos
Geklaut hat, kein
Spaß, ich hab letztens mal auf Youtube geguckt
Ist immer noch da
Grüße von Verena
Grüße zurück
Hast du erwähnt im Video
Ja so sieht's aus
Wer ist denn Verena? Wurde ich gehostet
Und hab's nicht gesehen? Oder ist das
Spam?
Man weiß ja hier nie
Moment, ah da guckt sich jemand
Haha, witzig
Da schaut sich jemand mein Klovideo an
Ja
Muss man Prioritäten setzen
Ist ein wichtiges Thema
Ihr könnt Verena sagen
Ich glaube der Klo
Ich hab den jetzt ja schon seit
10 Jahren
Der Klo war die beste
Investition ever
Also nehmen wir hier einen ordentlichen
Schreibtischstuhl, aber der Klo
War wirklich top
Top Investition
Okay
Weiter geht's, also
Jetzt hab ich das hier aufgemacht
Das hat mich jetzt abgelenkt, die ganze
Klo Thematik
Genau, wir sollten
Nämlich noch registrieren, ob
Wir nen Shutdown bekommen
Shutdown
Und dann sage ich
Connection
Stop
So jetzt bin ich
gespannt ob das funktioniert
Okay Leute, wenn ich jetzt
Ctrl-C drücke sollte es sich schneller beenden
Instant
Perfekt
Nice
Das ist gut
So muss das sein, so mag ich das
Ich nenn das immer so
Ihr kennt mich
Ich sag immer der Klo
Der Klo ist immer vor dem
Chef im Büro, ne Quatsch
Im Geschäft, nicht im Büro
Wie geht das?
Der Gerät
Schneidet das Dönerfleisch
Schweißfrei
Und
Ist immer vor dem Chef im
Keine Ahnung, ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen
So, haben wir aber ordentlich
was gemacht heute
Funktioniert schon richtig gut
So, Chat
Oh guck mal, der hat wieder
Ich muss das nochmal beenden und dem sagen, dass
der mal ein bisschen mehr Autos generaten soll
Ja, zwischen
3 und 15 Autos
Nee, komm, wenn schon dann richtig
Zwischen 15 und
69 Autos
Auf geht's, jetzt kackt
unser Frontend wahrscheinlich gleich ab
Bam, jawoll
Endlich mal hier
Ordentlich
Ordentlich Auto anzahlen, nicht so
Geringverdiener-Shit
So muss das sein
Guck, jetzt können wir auch ordentlich löschen
Und es funktioniert, nice
Das gefällt mir schon ausgesprochen gut
Das machen wir hier weg
Das Gute mit dem Klo ist,
dass man kein Klopapier braucht, naja
Das kommt ein bisschen
Das kommt ein bisschen auf den Geschmack an
Wie man das gerne macht
Ich muss sagen,
mein Fall ist es nicht ganz ohne
Klopapier
Ich benutze immer die Spülung und
dann nochmal Klopapier so zum
Trockenmachen hinterher
Rein mit dem Föhn
ist mir nix
Aber trotzdem muss man sagen, es ist so
angenehm, dass mit dem Wasser
im Vergleich nur mit Klopapier reiben
Ich kann es wirklich nur empfehlen
Sollte sich jeder
Sollte sich jeder gönnen, der
besten kann, so ein Klo
Einfach beste
Ist die Klobrille beheizbar?
Nein, das geht nicht
Du kannst, die Klobrille
kannst du nicht heizen
Aber
Da hab ich grad in meinem
Browserfenster rumgeklickt
und jetzt find ich meinen Chat nicht mehr
Warum bin ich in meinem Chat?
Mach ich einfach nochmal neu auf
Chat
Seid versteckt
Machst du Signal A Stuff?
Ja, korrekt
Also die Klobrille ist nicht beheizbar, aber das Wasser ist beheizbar
dass es nicht so kühl an Bobbes sprüht
Wobei
ich das persönlich ganz gern hab, wenn es nicht so
richtig kalt ist, aber auch nicht richtig warm
so ein bisschen
lauwarm
Ich würde euch übrigens empfehlen
Sollte irgendjemand so ein Klo kaufen wollen
Guckt mal nach
einem aktuellen Modell, nicht das was
ich hab. Mein Modell ist von 2013
Das ist mittlerweile schon viel besser
Und wahrscheinlich aber auch teurere
Wo kann man solche
Klos testen? Bei einem Sanitätshaus
deiner Wahl
in der Nähe. Musst du meistens vorher anrufen
und einen Termin ausmachen?
Ja, man muss quasi einen Termin zum Probesitzen ausmachen
Hab ich auch gemacht damals
bevor ich mir sowas gekauft hab
Sanitär, ja
hast recht
Hast ja nicht das Bein gebrochen oder so
Ist Dodge und Ram
nicht eigentlich dasselbe?
Keine Ahnung
Mag sein
Aber bei Fiat, beziehungsweise
über diese Stellantis
Arpis, nein
Dort ist das was unterschiedliches
Fiat hat einen Klo
Es ist ja auch ein nices Klo
Ich kann das nur empfehlen
Beste Klo ever
Es gibt sicherlich noch deutlich abgedrehtere
noch teurere, aber das muss nicht sein
Aber die Spülung ist das Beste
Kann sein, ich weiß es nicht
Leute, ich kenn mich mit den
Fiat-Marken, beziehungsweise mit den Landesmarken
nicht aus, ich weiß nur, dass es für die
Arpi nicht das gleiche ist
Weil die Endpoints
Ich kann es euch noch zeigen, guckt mal hier
Fiat Champ Addon
Das ist das
wie es aktuell ist
Fiat Champ Addon, so
Hier gibt es ganz viele
Unterschiede, je nachdem was ihr habt
RAM und Dodge
Login-URL ist
Login-US-RAM-Trucks
Und Dodge ist
Login-US-Dodge.com
Sieht jetzt zwar ähnlich aus
sind aber unterschiedliche Sachen
Witzigerweise, der Arpi-Key ist
der gleiche
Ne, der Arpi-Key ist einfach nur der gleiche
Wisst ihr warum das der gleiche ist?
Weil wir den Copy-Pasted haben und ich habe es nie ausprobiert
Aber das Login
ist definitiv unterschiedlich und es wird
wahrscheinlich nichts funktionieren
dass du das eine über das andere abrufst
Gut
Okay Chat, wo machen wir weiter?
Wir haben doch jetzt wirklich schon ganz gut Progress gemacht
Wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit
Ihr könnt euch das jetzt aussuchen
Ich habe einen Vorschlag
an euch Chat
Entweder basteln wir jetzt
noch so 45 Minuten weiter, dann gehe ich pennen
Oder
wir gucken uns noch ein paar Youtube-Videos an
Wobei das machen wir morgen
früh schon, ich wäre ja fast schon für 45 Minuten
noch weiter basteln
Weil
zum Beispiel könnte man ja noch mal
das Formular zum
zum hinzufügen
adden
Ja, gute Umfrage
Chat, könnt ihr euch aussuchen
Okay, weiter
basteln wird wahrscheinlich gewinnen
Es sei denn
es sind mehrere Abstimmungen erlaubt
und jetzt kommen die Leute wieder mit Kanalpunkten um die Ecke
Das
kommt ja öfters mal vor
Aha, ja trotzdem
haben die unterschiedliche Apis
Oh nein, es geht los, die Channel Points
werden reingehauen
Aber weiter basteln hat gewonnen
Das ist okay, wir gucken morgen früh
Ich bin morgen früh wieder 8.30 Uhr
9 Uhr so in dem Dreh am Start
Und dann machen wir unsere wöchentliche
Youtube-Guck-Aktion
Magst du dich ans Trinken erinnern?
Dankeschön, habe ich aber schon
Bog
Okay, dann würde ich sagen
Wir
bauen jetzt mal noch
den Account-Adden-Dialog
Hab ich
Ihr habt ja aufgepasst, ihr seid ja
schlau, Chat, 5Hat
HiIQ, hab ich irgendwas
Essentielles nicht bedacht oder
vergessen?
Hab ich irgendwas
Ja, nicht vergessen, dass ich
heute Morgen 5 Omas über die Straßen
geholfen habe und
2 verletzte Haustiere
zum Tierarzt gefahren
Oder was auch immer sonst so Eindruck macht
Also
hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Irgendwas
Ich glaube nicht
Ne, glaub nicht
Ne, dann machen wir mal weiter
Also, wenn man hier auf das Plus klickt, da brauchen wir
ein Formular, dass man Sachen hinzufügen kann
Man Accounts hinzufügen kann
Wer von euch hat
die CSS-Skills, Leute?
Und ich meine nicht Counter-Strike
Wer hat
die krassen CSS-Skills? Ist der Auskennfuchs da?
Für das Formular brauchen
wir irgendjemand, der fit ist mit CSS
Da hört's bei mir
auf
Ich fürchte rein mit
Diff-Centern kommen wir noch nicht mal weiter
Also, wir kommen wahrscheinlich
kommen wir mit Diff-Centern nicht weiter
Wir brauchen jetzt
eine neue Route und zwar
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Plus, Create
Oh
Files with Prefixed
Plus Reserved
Warum?
Routing
Was?
Das hab ich doch
Ah, neuer Ordner
Okay
Vorne Create
Und dann darf das nicht Create heißen, sondern wahrscheinlich
Okay, verstehe
Ich glaube, ich hab's gecheckt
Wir kopieren meine Page und die
kopieren wir in Create
Ja, das passt
So
Also, Page Copy
Nee, Page Copy soll das nicht heißen
Aber so
Create
Ja, nice, funktioniert, sehr schön
Hast du eigentlich gesehen, dass man
mit CSS auch Datenbank-Requests machen kann?
Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen, aber wahrscheinlich
kann man nicht direkt Datenbank-Requests machen, sondern
irgendwelche Parser, die
nicht richtig Escaping ausnutzen
Ja
Chat, Chat, ich weiß
Ich weiß, dass grad mein Klo-Video geguckt wird
Du bist, Jörgi, du bist nicht der Erste, der
es gepostet hat
Wir müssen jetzt eigentlich mal so richtig
das Twitch- und YouTube-Game
machen, und zwar
so wie die ganzen
High-IQ-Profi-Streamer
das machen. Ich muss einfach
morgen auf das Video von
Iri reacten, wie sie
auf mein Video reactet
Das ist das High-IQ-YouTube-Game
So muss man das machen
Wenn ich mir das aktuell auf YouTube angucke, was
ich in YouTube Deutschland für ein Shit empfohlen bekomme
Alter, das ist Wahnsinn
KuchenTV reagiert auf MontanaBlack
reagiert auf Shurioka
reagiert auf Anwalt Solmecke
Du hast, ich hatte letztens
Ohne Scheiß
Ich hab letztens gesehen in einem Video
Das war ein
Quads
Reaction-Video
Da waren fünf Videos ineinander
geschachtelt mit Webcams
Und zwei Webcams war der
gleiche Typ
Man hat ihn doppelt gesehen, quasi von damals
und von jetzt
Also das Reaction
Inception geht komplett
außer Kontrolle, gerade auf YouTube
Am Ende geht's so um Energydrinks
Ja
Oder wer irgendwen
angeblich gefilmt hat
und was auch immer
Ich hab's versucht nach Möglichkeiten zu ignorieren
Ich ignoriere eigentlich so gut wie alles was
YouTube Deutschland
Twitter Deutschland, YouTube Twitch
Beef angesagt ist
Leute, ich bin mittlerweile
fast 39
Also
Ich hab echt
andere Probleme als
mich mit YouTube Beef zu beschäftigen
Worum geht's in dem
Klo-Video?
Naja, ich zeig mein Klo
Es gibt sogar
übrigens zwei Videos davon
Ein Video von vor paar Jahren
und ein neues Video dazu
Update-Video
High-Performer-Mindset
Leute, heute
Wir müssen jetzt noch die Login-Form
Ne, nicht Login-Form
Die Create-Form bauen
Ja, heute
programmieren wir uns auf den Mount Everest
So, jetzt brauch ich Leute mit CSS-Skills
Forms
Ja, random win, lass gut sein
Am Ende ist es doch alles nur
übelst cringe
Richtig, Yonderboy, so seh ich das auch
Wenigstens
was Vernünftiges
CSS, das ist das erste Mal, dass jemand
gesagt hat, dass CSS vernünftig ist
Also, wir brauchen
sowas wie
Ja
Create Account
Nice, beste
Fertig, oder? Easy
Ich würd sagen, Arbeit erledigt
Muss reichen
Done
Ursprünglich nur durch Max
zu Twitch gekommen
Nice
Ich bin erstaunt, wie viele Leute
mittlerweile da sind, die YouTube
gar nicht kennen
Wir haben letztens mal eine Umfrage gemacht
Wie habt ihr den Channel gefunden?
Beziehungsweise, wie habt ihr mich auf Twitch gefunden?
Über YouTube? Oder kommt ihr direkt von irgendwelchen
Twitch-Empfehlungen? Und es waren erstaunlich viele
wirklich nur von Twitch da
Da haben wir kein Kommando für
Gab's eigentlich schon die Gehaltsumfrage
Ja
Haben wir doch letztens gemacht
Wie viele Stonks gibt's?
Scorcho, danke für den Sub
10 Monate
Nice
Ich fänd's ja schon irgendwie cool
Das hatten wir ja schon öfters
im Stream, ja? Wenn die Leute
schreiben, Max
Und ich muss sagen, das war damals gar nicht meine
Intention mit den Videos, ja?
Wenn die Leute schreiben, Max, ich mach jetzt eine Ausbildung
oder ich hab mich jetzt entschieden, das und das
zu lernen oder Programmieren zu lernen oder ich
studiere jetzt Informatik
oder was auch immer und du hast mich dazu irgendwie
gebracht
Ich hab die Videos damals
nicht wirklich
Ich hab damals nicht wirklich lange drüber nachgedacht
Ich hab gedacht, okay, könnte vielleicht den
einen oder anderen interessieren, aber dass
Jahre später die Leute zu mir
kommen und sagen, Max, nur wegen dir hab ich die Ausbildung
gemacht, beziehungsweise nur wegen dir fang ich
jetzt an oder nur wegen dir hab ich vor 5, 6 Jahren
die Ausbildung gemacht, das ist schon cool
Ja, das hab ich
Das hab ich damals damit nicht mitgerechnet
Ja, die Videos kommen auch immer
ganz gut an, wenn ich irgendwelche
Storys erzähle. Ich hätte noch
ein paar
Ich müsste glaube ich mal wieder einfach
in ein Erzählvideo machen. Guck mal, mein letztes Video
ist doch auch schon wieder richtig
schlange her
Guck mal hier
Also außerdem sind die letzten 3 Videos
gar nicht so gut angekommen. Guck mal, Battle Bit
hab ich gedacht, kommt besser an
Das hab ich auch gedacht, kommt besser an
Und den Speedrun hab ich auch, auch wenn es so eine Stream-Reaction ist
hab ich auch gedacht, kommt besser an
Davor 50k, 50k
80k, 50k
Na gut, es schwankt immer mal
ein bisschen. 80, ja
Aber die letzten 3 Videos haben sich sogar
aber kein Bock
Sommerferien, gerade Sommerferien
sitzen die Kinder vorm Handy und gucken YouTube
Aber davon abgesehen, die Kinder
gucken sich nicht das hier an
Die gucken es eher
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich angesagt? Fortnite ist es doch
auch nicht mehr, oder?
Was ist denn jetzt der angesagte Shit im Gaming-Bereich?
Also es ist seit Jahren schon
immer wieder Minecraft, das weiß ich
Aber Fortnite, Fortnite gucken
bestimmt noch viele Leute, aber
was ist denn aktuell so das
Kinder-Game?
Wo die ganzen 12-Jährigen
Ja, du bist so schlecht, ich geb dir Header
Leute jetzt unterwegs sind
Roblox?
Immer noch?
Das gibt es doch auch schon ewig
Roblox gibt es doch auch schon irgendwie
20 Jahre
Äh, nicht ganz
10 Jahre oder so
2006, Mann
15 Jahre
Ich versteh übrigens beim besten Willen nicht
warum Leute Roblox spielen
Das meiste was ich gesehen hab
bisher immer so von Roblox
sind irgendwelche anderen Games
nachgebaut
nur in schlecht in Roblox
Wo ich mir immer frage
warum
warum spielt man das dann
in Roblox anstatt das Game zu spielen
was im Original besser ist
Ja doch, also warum man
sich Gaming-Videos anschaut, verstehe ich
voll und ganz
Man guckt sich Gaming-Videos an
weil man sich vielleicht Tipps holen will
weil man gucken will wie andere spielen
weil man vielleicht selbst besser werden will in dem Game
Was ich noch nie verstanden habe ist
warum sich Leute
den ganzen Tag
Let's Plays reinziehen
Ich gucke
sehr vereinzelt ab und zu
auch mal das ein oder andere
Let's Play
Ich glaube wirklich fertig geguckt hab ich nur wenige
und dann sind das von uralten 16-Bit Games
gewesen
Let's Play Faszination
verstehe ich auch nicht ganz
Also ich kann es schon irgendwie nachvollziehen
Ja, aber es ist halt nichts für mich
Nee, Warzone ist doch auch gar nicht mehr angesagt
Ich bekomme nur mit
dass die ganzen Warzone-Streamer
aktuell übelst Warzone haten
weil Warzone 2 viel schlechter ist
als Warzone 1 angeblich
und alles
vernoobt und alles, ach keine Ahnung
Ja, verstehe ich auch nicht
Ich meine ich kann verstehen warum man sich
Gronkh anguckt irgendwie
Also von deutschen Let's Playern geht ja noch voll klar
Aber
wie gesagt
doch ich verstehe es irgendwo warum es die Leute
gucken, aber ich kann es nicht
für mich persönlich jetzt nachvollziehen
Also ich kann mir schon Sachen
überlegen was die Leute daran finden
aber ich finde da halt nichts dran
So, ja
Zum Einschlafen
Zum Einschlafen gucke ich keine Let's Plays
gucke ich immer
Videos über das Universum und sowas
Keine Ahnung
Die 10
größten schwarzen
Löcher die je entdeckt wurden
Die 5 Galaxien
sowieso, da gucke ich immer irgendwelche Videos
Ich gucke so
Wissenschaftsdinger gerne
Oder was ich auch mega gerne gucke zum
Einschlafen sind irgendwelche
Vorträge
Sei es jetzt
Irgendwie von
Aber das darf mich nicht so wahnsinnig
interessieren
Also ich kann mir beispielsweise
zum Einschlafen schlecht jetzt
ein Video angucken von irgendeiner .net Konferenz
mit einem Thema was mich interessiert
Das kann ich mir zum Einschlafen nicht gut angucken
Was ich mir wunderbar zum Einschlafen angucken kann
sind irgendwelche Mathe-Geschichten
zum Beispiel oder
Also irgendwas was mich so
am Rande schon irgendwo interessiert
aber nicht genug um jetzt
da eine Stunde zu gucken
Also irgendwelche
Irgendwelche
Musik-Vorlesung
Mathe-Vorlesung
Vorlesung ist jetzt das falsche Wort
Ich gucke mir da keine Uni-Vorlesung, irgendwelche Vorträge
Kann ich mir gut angucken
Oder
Weiß gar nicht was, was gucke ich
ansonsten? Ja, ich gucke
unglaublich gerne zum Pen
irgendwelche Lore-Videos
über Games
Also, auch Games
die ich nicht spiele
Ja, für C++-Konferenzen
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich da gut
einschlafen könnte dabei
Ja, also ich gucke
gerne zum Beispiel Lore-Videos
über
World of Warcraft Lore-Videos
Ich spiele kein World of Warcraft, ich habe nie großartig
World of Warcraft gespielt
Ich habe zum Release ein bisschen gespielt, aber
Damals galte World of Warcraft
als Noob-MMO, muss man sich mal heute für heute
vorstellen
Damals
Ich gucke mir World of Warcraft Lore-Videos
an, Dungeons & Dragons
Lore-Videos, da gibt es ja
Tausende auf YouTube von
Und das ist so ein Thema, das ist so ein bisschen
wie Geschichten erzählen, das kann man im Hintergrund
laufen lassen, ich habe da auch schon ein paar
Channels, wo die Leute eine relativ beruhigende
Stimme haben und nicht so laufend
eskalieren und ausflippen
Das kann ich wunderbar im Hintergrund
laufen lassen
Food-Videos
Okay, Food-Videos
Wo ist mein Handy?
Kann ich grad mal gucken
Zahnarzt ist übelst teuer geworden, ich war am
Letzte Woche
war ich beim Zahnarzt, hab eine
Zahnreinigung machen lassen
Und das kostet mittlerweile
80 Euro
Das ist jetzt nicht so als
käme es mir da auf ein paar Cent an oder so
Aber ich glaube
Vor ein paar Jahren hat es noch 40 Euro oder so
gekostet
Das ist jetzt einfach 100% teurer
Aber es ist eh brutal teuer alles
Ich war heute
essen
Also in einem Restaurant
essen, also ordentlich, ordentliches
Futter
Und
Ich hab mich ja schon abgeschminkt, dass
ich irgendwie was davor esse oder ein Salat
noch esse oder Nachtisch esse
Mach ich ja alles nicht mehr
Ich bestell mir ein Hauptgericht und gut ist
Und
Ich hab am Ende
Für zwei Personen am
Ende
48 Euro in dem Dreh bezahlt, ja
Sidetracked
Ja hast recht, egal
Jetzt lohnt
sich auch nicht mehr High IQ Zeug zu machen
Wir schwätzen jetzt noch
20 Minuten, dann geh ich ins Bett, so war mal das
Ja, ungefähr
50 Euro hab ich bezahlt
Hast du allein für zwei Personen gegessen? Nein
Meine Mutter war dabei, die hat Geburtstag
gehabt, vor paar Tagen
Ähm, das hat
ziemlich, also aufgerundet 50 Euro
gekostet, schon ordentlich
Ja, einfach nur Hauptspeise
für zwei Personen
Und was, und, und was zu trinken
Ne Flasche Wasser
für zwei Personen, null
Also jetzt nicht so als hätten wir da
übertrieben, 50 Euro
Schon nicht schlecht
Schon ordentlich
Was?
Boah, das ist ja krass, Alter
War das beim Oktoberfest oder wie letztes Jahr?
17 Euro
für drei Cola, was ist mit denen los?
Also das Wasser
heute hat glaube ich 4,50 Euro gekostet
Was auch schon übertrieben viel ist eigentlich
für eine Flasche Wasser, die kriegst du im Automat
für 50 Cent, oder
ja, oder im
im Kasten mit
sind im Kasten drinne 12 oder so
Das sind auch viel weniger, ach das ist schon
wirklich richtig heftig teuer geworden
Leute, ich muss jetzt mal euch
was erzählen, wo wir grad dabei sind
Wer von euch spielt gerade
Baldur's Gate 3?
Keine Spoiler, keine Sorge
Keine Spoiler
Und mich würde folgendes mal
interessieren, falls wir Leute haben, die die spielen
Findet ihr
dass das von der Atmosphäre
beziehungsweise vom Feeling her an
die alten Games anknüpft
oder eher an Divinity
Originals Sin 2
Das ist nämlich so genau das, wo ich meine
Bedenken hatte
bevor ich es mir gekauft hab
wo ich mir schon gedacht hab, ah
es sieht ein bisschen eher aus
wie Divinity Originals Sin 2
und also meiner Sicht spielt es sich auch
eindeutig mehr danach
und es sieht auch vom ganzen Stil her
und von den Menüs
und vom Inventar
und es sieht einfach alles
mehr nach Divinity Originals Sin 2 aus
Versteht mich denn falsch? Das war auch ein geiles Game
Sowohl der erste als der zweite Teil
Also Divinity
1 und 2
Also Originals Sin 1 und 2
Es gab ja noch mehr Divinity Spiele
Aber so ganz von der Atmosphäre
hat es mich bisher noch nicht
gepackt und außerdem sind mir
und das muss ich sagen, das dachte ich mir auch im Vorfeld
schon, das hat sich auch bestätigt
Außerdem sind wir, sind mir
4, ist eine 4er Party
ist mir zu klein. Ich hätte lieber
eine 6er Party
So wie in den alten Games
Hast einfach viel mehr Möglichkeiten
Du spielst so
Du hast ja relativ viele
Gefährten, die du rekrutieren kannst
Ich glaube es gibt 15 Stück
Insgesamt sogar in dem Game
Aber du wirst am Ende exakt mit den
Zeichen rumrennen
und
die Hälfte ignorieren
und mit der 6er Party
konntest du wenigstens deine 6 Favorites reinhauen
Okay
5, weil dein
dein, dein
ja Anführer NPC
und dein Anführer Player Charakter nicht NPC
ähm
den, den hast du ja nicht, ja
Also mir wäre eine 6er Party tatsächlich
deutlich lieber gewesen
Ich habe auch deswegen mit einem Origin Charakter
angefangen, dass ich quasi
wenigstens Story habe bei 4 Characters
Also bei meinem Origin Charakter
plus bei den anderen 3
Ja, aber du bist halt
ziemlich festgefahren, ich meine wenn du das
ein bisschen, ich spiele das natürlich auch schwer
logischerweise, weil
wenn schon, dann ein bisschen Challenge
Ja, aber du kannst halt nur 4 Stück mitnehmen
das ist das Problem
Ja, deswegen
spiele ich das natürlich auch ein bisschen optimist
hab natürlich auch gleich die, die
Charakter Points neu verteilen und alles
ähm
und ich weiß gar nicht so genau, also
du musst, du musst eigentlich immer mit den
gleichen spielen, du hast einen Cleric
zur Auswahl, den musst du mitnehmen
wenn du nicht selbst einer bist, das ist keine Chance
der wird dabei sein, Shadowheart ist dabei
von Anfang bis Ende des Games
du wirst nicht viel, ich meine
du könntest den Druide mitnehmen, aber ohne Cleric
suckt, außerdem ist Cleric mit eines der
besten Klassen, die es überhaupt gibt
nen Wizard brauchst du auch
kommst du auch nicht drumherum, eventuell
könntest du den ersetzen durch
was anderes, aber ich meine es gibt ja
nur einen Wizard als
äh Compagnon
also hast du schon mal 2 von 4, die du
eigentlich mitnehmen musst, so
dann brauchst du noch einmal Frontline
Frontline gibt's eigentlich
auch nur 2, die taugen
also insofern, meine ist
ein bisschen eingeschränkt
also ne 6er Party wäre mir
viel lieber gewesen, so
aber genug rumgerantet, weil
ansonsten ist das Game mega nice
ich bin aber noch nicht so weit, ich habe jetzt
irgendwie
8-9 Stunden gespielt
bin wahrscheinlich nicht mal halb
fertig mit Akt 1 oder so
ich habe ja Leute im Early Access gesehen, die haben in Akt 1
irgendwie 100 plus Stunden oder so reingesteckt
ja
das macht aber nix, weil
die Mods rebalancen das Game ja nicht
wenn das Game gebalanced ist
für 4 Charakter, kannst du nicht einfach
mit nem 8er Mod spielen
und dann
bist du happy, das funktioniert
nicht, das ist viel viel zu
einfach mit 8 Spielern
wenn es gebalanced ist für 4
du hast einfach doppelt so viele
Actions und Action Economy ist quasi
eines der wichtigsten Sachen
in der 5.
Dungeons & Dragons Ausgabe
deswegen musst du immer Gegner
downbursten, das ist eh das Beste, was du machen kannst
ja, also
ein 8er Party Mod
bringt gar nix
weil das Game wahrscheinlich damit
auch noch rumbacken wird
naja, ansonsten ist das Game
top, also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen
dass du da sehr sehr lange dran
Spaß haben kannst, gerade wenn man jemand ist, der
gerne alle möglichen Sachen ausprobiert und erforscht
und es hat sicherlich auch einen hohen Wiederspielwert
weil du halt viele Sachen
erst beim ersten Durchlauf gar nicht
mitbekommst
naja, also insofern
sicherlich ein gutes Game
aber für mich hat es nicht
es ist kein
Ballus G3
es hat nichts so richtig von
dem
Player der Originalspiele und von der Atmosphäre
und von dem Stil der Originalspiele
und auch 4er Party vs.
6 ist doof
aber es ist ein richtig gutes
RPG
das muss man sagen
ich gehe jetzt pennen
wobei ich gehe noch nicht pennen, es ist 21.25
Keck Wait, Alter, warum sollte ich schon pennen gehen
es ist noch ein bisschen früh vielleicht
da gucke ich jetzt noch ein bisschen Serie
oder irgendwie noch ein paar Youtube Videos
oder Twitch Streams
nee, nicht jetzt
ein bisschen bevor ich dann
so Richtung
bevor es Richtung Nachtruhe geht
muss ich
ich kann nicht bis 5 Minuten
davor ins Bett
bis 5 Minuten vors Bett gehen, mein Hirn anstrengen
da kann ich nicht pennen
machen wir lieber morgen noch ein bisschen weiter
schon Gonon gezockt, ja
nein, hab ich nicht
hab ich nicht
und ganz ehrlich, die Entschuldigung
an die Community
hab ich auch schon geschrieben, bevor das Game überhaupt
released wurde
das wäre so ein richtiges
Top Beispiel gewesen
AAA Gaming in 2023
vor 3 wird nicht gepennt
doch, ich stehe samstags auch
um kurz vor 7 auf
oder 7 Uhr kurz vor 7 auf
morgen auch, dementsprechend bin ich
22 Uhr schon platt
ich hab heute wieder massig, heute war ich
richtig viel unterwegs
also Kilometer mäßig
am Vormittag am Stück
und ich hab jetzt ja auch meine
Fitness Tracker Uhr am Start
meine neue
Fitness Tracker Uhr, das motiviert
nochmal doppelt, wenn man dann alles
genau aufzeichnen und kontrollieren kann
ja, richtig
die wollen jetzt nur noch Publishen
ok Chat
wir sehen uns morgen früh, bis denn
zur halb 9, 9 wieder, wie immer
machts gut, see you